I
Wow
Oh
I'm sorry, I just woke up
Well, not really just woke up. I woke up not too long ago, and then I scarfed down
Mama's food and then ran down here
But today we're playing Omari
Looking kind of pale there, so does this guy on screen
I
Ain't on controller. What did mama cook? Um
Banh-hi a Vietnamese food called banh-hi
It was very delicious
I
Was very delicious
Have you played Omori before I have a little bit oh shoot hold on
It's capturing my cursor. Let's fix that
Don't worry
Everything is going to be okay
Only you're sobbing no matter what happens
Promise me that will always be there
I
Miss me
Welcome to white space
You
Can I go into the game yet?
Is you are used to it? You have been living here for so for as long as you can remember
Tonight is
I
Think I'm in the gameplay zone
So give me a second as I fix the capture a bit so it doesn't capture the cursor
Because sometimes I need my cursor on my screen, but I don't want you guys to see it
My I don't want to see my senpai see it
I
Totally I played up to some bears and that was it
A tissue box for wiping your sorrows away I
Have one right here beside me too and a big
big
industrial amount for senpai's I
Don't
You booted up your laptop
What would you like to do stare at your screen
You stared at the screen, what would you like to do open your journal?
Today I spent time in white space everything was okay today. I spent time in white space everything was okay
Everything, okay
Yay, what would you like to do log off a
Heat from the laptop warmed your lap felt nice
Your sketchbook take a look inside
Huh
All right, all right
All right
How artistic of them
Oh
What is that it's not a piece of meat or a flat night ball
assistant
Meal me wall meal meal
Waiting for something to happen
Something fell nearby oh a knife. What is this thing? Oh
A knife you got a shiny knife
Those things all right
Waiting for something to happen
Oh
Why door cast a hate chattel
What would you like to do open the door
Stop having it be closed
Oh so colorful
Oh
Hi Amore you're hoping that you come by soon and play cards with us. We're just about to start another game. Oh
Whoops never mind. Oh
Man what the heck Aubrey you messed up all the cards. I was winning too
Hey there, Kel. There's no need to get angry. It's just a game after all
Don't give me that hero you only say that cuz you were losing
I look at other stuff disgusting. I hate eggs
Tentacles poking out of the ground
You got stuff toy. Oh, yeah, a
Single bean on a plate just like that one
Just like that one what do you call it?
Do you remember the Jack in the beanstalk?
Uh
Where they cut they were about to cut the bean into like tiny loose little slices, that's what it looks like
A photo of someone familiar
Would you like to make toast
Whoa toast you may toast. Oh, give me the toast you may toast. Oh, okay
A fluffy pillow shaped like the head of a girl a neatly wrapped present a blender
It's all right a
Baseball and a baseball bat
I can't shape toll
There's a movie on TV or boys are walking on a rail road tracks
Oh
I just kill
Cal
Why is Cal always so mean to me?
You know the other day that good for nothing stole my stuffed toy and hid it somewhere in this room
Why would he do something like that?
So mature
I mean, what did I ever do to him?
Oh, I know
Can you find my stuffed toy for me? Oh, Maury?
Please pretty please. Oh, well, I already did
It is that could it be
Aubrey snatched the stuffed toy from you
Hey Cal look, it's my stuffed toy
Did you get that I'm already found it lucky for me. I've got some real friends
Serves you right Cal you should know better than to pick on others
But Aubrey started it
She was the one who was making fun of me for the mole on my
On your
Aubrey
Oh
Thank you. Oh, Maury, I knew you I could count on you. You're the best
Hey, oh Maury, I'm glad that's all settled those two always seem to be bumping heads
Maury and basal invited us for a
Picnic at the playground
Want to go see them?
Sure
All right, everyone. Let's go see Maury and basal
Oh, look we're online and that's Nick's
Huh, I never noticed the cat moved his eyes
Here
Waiting for something to happen. Yeah
Going on Maury
Here's your allowance for today
You got 50 clams. Oh
Yeah, fresh air at last all of that nature. Well, let's go
Hey, wait a sec
Help me help me up guys. I'm stuck
Only if only if you say please
Yeah, stop messing around get me out of here. Okay, okay fine
Took you long enough. Well, sorry princess
Yes
Hang on this way
Spider
You are afraid of spiders. Okay, not this way then. Oh
strong a
mommy
strong a will call
Welcome to the stream welcome raiders to the stream
Raid raid raid
Bacon durian streamer only did nine hours. I'm a failure. What do you mean only nine hours?
Oh
Only nine hours whatever I whatever next
Only next time you're gonna tell me all I only did 16 hours. I'm such a failure. I
Would like to do something and I'll be
Oh, it's okay. Oh, no. Oh, give me a second
Okay, sorry about that
Sorry about that mama and papa were a little loud. So I was like, oh, I better mute just in case
But yeah
Have fun in Omori. I've never played it before or seen footage of it. Oh my
Well, you can see while you're going to snooze mamae you can watch me play it
I'm gonna build a sandcastle with your friends. Of course
Oh a bolt my knees
The world
Castle okay, well at least someone did the project correctly someone got the memo
Oh
That was nice
What was that you're afraid of drowning well, ooh
Time to go a different direction then
Oh
A giant pinwheel
You're afraid of heights, okay, what am I not afraid of?
Oh
Okay, we stay afraid
Why are there eggs everywhere I hate eggs. Oh, this is a nice playground though wonderful really
Oh
Hold on guys
Sorry, I'm going to be
Today it looks like I might be like I might be like muted and like BRB
Intermittently because surprisingly at this time mama and papa are
Kind of active usually stream at night so that they're sleeping but it seems like they're they're very awake right now
They're not fighting they're just excited
they were on
They were on a call with my I think they were on a call with my
My sister
What don't misinterpret that weirdos my little senpai's need to go to the electric Cushion chair chamber right now
Oh
My gosh
No
Is your sister singer now first off now
I'm saying they're active as in like they're awake and not sleeping aren't watching Netflix
Their favorite hobby is to watch Netflix
Are you single am I single
I'm in a loving relationship with my senpai's
And chill don't think naughty things about my family you can only think about naughty things about me
What are they watching I think they've been watching Korean dramas
So right now they're they've been watching all sorts of things
They've been watching all sorts of things on Netflix
Guess who pays for Netflix
All sorts of things yeah like
The other day
Mama mama she came up to me and was like
Was like you should watch sorry, let me try to mimic her voice a little bit you should watch
City Hunter I hear there's an anime about it. It was such a good live-action sweetie
I
Would they watch your streams no
No
they know that I love anime but
Papa
Assumes every anime is Sailor Moon or Inuyasha because of my obsession with both of them as a kid
Do they know you stream let's keep this between me and you senpai
I've tried to explain what I do for
Work and they've got it in their head that I'm teaching English online
Like when I said I was doing my debut stuff and I was doing like a I was preparing for debut
For my for my new job. They were like, oh, you've got an interview sweetie. Okay, we'll be quiet
Are you teaching a new school? Are you teaching new kids English?
And I was like no no no it's I already got the job I already got the job
I just it's today's like a performance day today's a performance day
So every we have to be super quiet so that it'll be like it's my first time meeting everyone
They're like, oh, okay, so so how long is your interview dear?
Hahaha
So I've tried multiple times
I've tried multiple times to explain what I do so senpais
Keep this a secret between me and you okay, I think they're happy that I'm getting a bit of money
Getting a bit of money now. They were so worried before
Do we have a word of the day
Let me choose a word
How about diligence hmm our word of the day is diligence. Yeah work hard
Is
That the safe word there's no safe words around me silly it's only safe words around chibi
She she acknowledges yours
I
Hearing she bees hearing is selective when it comes to safe words. Yeah
So we don't have that okay because you're always safe with me senpai don't worry about it
Yeah, any time I keep all of my senpais in my basement
My parents are just like all these must be the new students
I've tried to explain multiple times every
Time it's gets misconstrued like any time
Netflix goes down they always
They're not very
They don't really know about technology, so they're like
Sweetie the Netflix is down
Netflix is down
Can you call Netflix to tell them to bring it back?
I
Yeah, sure
That's like give me a second I'll fix this I'll fix this
Usually the issue is with my my ISP
My ISP so it's not usually
So yeah
My parents are very sweet people. I love them very much and that's why I really want to be successful
So that I can provide for them, but also I kind of want to move out because
Well, you know
You don't really a lot of privacy when living with your parents because my time is always their time
So any time I tell them okay, I'm at work right now
I'm at work right now, so I can't I can't do I can't do things until maybe like until I'm done, okay?
They don't normally get that and sometimes will interrupt and be like
And so I'm just like, okay, okay, we go
Honestly, they don't want me to move
I've been telling them like oh, yeah, I'm thinking about moving and they're like no no no no no no no no no
No, don't move. We need you
No, please don't move
It's so funny because um, oh my gosh, I'm so I'm I'm yapping. I'm yapping. I haven't even played the game
I haven't even played. I'm so sorry. I'm still yapping
When when okay, here's a fun fact about about me senpai's I worked I worked in Japan
I didn't at an internship or
Or um for about three months. Mm-hmm. So I lived in Japan for three months and um
And um, I was like, oh, yeah, you know, if I get a job offer here, I'll stay and
Mama and Papa were like if you're moving to Japan, we are moving to Japan
Oh
But I really want to want my privacy because um for patreon and stuff I have to go into like a pretty much, um
Uh really a secluded room with like, uh, I put like a bunch of clothing around to to soundproof it a bit
It's not ideal. It's not an ideal situation
Yeah closet it's pretty much a closet recording
So I would really love to like one of my goals is to like move out so that I'll be able to have a space to work
Yeah
So I'm I'm trying to convince them that if I do move out, I'll I'll I'll move out
But I'll be I'll be really close to help them out
So all of my audios have been kind of like in a closet. Yeah
So don't worry about it
It's a little awkward. Yeah, I think I feel like it's a little awkward, but
um
I am bringing in some money so
So they'll be happy and as long as I'm able to pay pay off the bills and stuff
I think though they're pretty happy about that
like, um
For a little bit I have to ask
uh, I used to be the one
to pay for like gas and electricity and like utilities, but then I
I couldn't find a job so
So I um
I um, I yeah, I la
I had to ask them and they were so worried about about it
Um
Did your sister escape the raft? Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, she oh, yeah, she did
the moment
um
she
Could get out
Uh, she was like, okay. I'm sending abroad
Bye
And she just left
No, my sister's not single. She's married trying to trying to I think she's trying to adopt
Uh adopt adopt and then I'm I was the one that was like, okay, you're stuck now
It was really um
It was really tough the job market here is pretty tough
Like I tried to apply to to mcdonald's and they didn't even accept me
Well, mostly because they wanted the morning shift and I'm allergic to eggs
So they didn't want to bear the responsibility for that either
But like a lot of places like they just they were like no we have
like uh here it's such a job desert that I think even the most basic, uh
Customer service job has over us the average here is 700
Uh applicants per job
No matter what it is
You
So it's uh, it's hard it's been hard here
So it's it's not easy
Um, honestly, uh to be honest before I got the
The email for
VLR
I
Was in line for seven hours seven hours at a job there
It was it was harsh
It was harsh. It was really harsh
No way my sister is uh, it's fine something about my sister
But yeah, I was so glad when I got the the call I was like, oh my gosh finally I can I can I can start providing again
Um, yeah before I was uh doing a lot of jobs and then when cold it hit it was um, it was gone
It's a pretty cool cool one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I'm hoping
I'm really happy that uh strani gave me the opportunity. So yeah, I'm really thankful
I get to be with my supplies as well and also provide
Provide a bit although I'm hoping definitely I I'll I'll be able to have money to provide and also move out
I would love
Have a bit of in a privacy
But yeah
A bit of privacy, um
Uh privacy would be nice
But thank you everyone. Sorry. I literally just felt my entire situation
I trauma dumped on on on on my senpai's it's okay
So, yeah, that's that's my that's my situation
And that's why they're a bit loud sometimes. So that's why I'll have
Occasionally I'll have to pause stream and be like I gotta check what's up like actually one time um at the pause stream
because uh
Uh papa papa fell down and like he he cut his eyebrow open and I was like, okay stream's ending. Bye
Gotta go to the hospital
Oh my gosh, I'm I'm such a yapper. I'm so sorry is anyone is anyone like right now go I just play the game dart and streamer
I
Pretty chill game though. Okay, let's continue hold on
I think they've quieted down now. I really brought this up because like I could still hear them
I could still hear them uh talking. I think they were on the phone with uh sister
Give me a moment
I'm still a little sick. I think I've overworked myself a little bit for debut
No, it's fine. Don't worry
Um
I said the other day like after after debut I stood up and like literally collapsed onto my knees because I was like
I was so tense
Uh, I've got a lot of time in between um or my streams so I'll be fine
Is papa good now of course
Of course papa's fine the hospital took care of him really fast
Oh, but on my day off days off though, I feel like I'm gonna have to record some audios. I'm a little behind
Is papa single
Oh
Mons cut cut off this cut off his testicles
I'm not being mean always just being all whiny
Well, Cal you've just made a very convincing point. Now. I don't know who to believe
Believe me. No, believe me
Uh that'll down you too. Why does it always have to be like this?
Chin up hero look at you being unresponsible
I really like that about you
Come on Mari not now. Oh hero, you know, I'm just teasing you're so cute when you get all flustered
Well, we're all waiting for you guys based on I we're going through this it's photo album. Did you want to join us?
Of course after all we're the ones in the pictures, aren't we?
basil basil get a lot of this
Come on basil take a picture of me
Sorry Cal. I only take photos of people when they least expect it
You like to take photos of people acting naturally when they're not in front of the camera, right basil?
Yeah, there's something special about everyone living on their own lives
These are those are the moments I want to capture
So like we just have to pretend you're not there
Yeah, I guess you can put it that way
Sure, I can do that
Did did you want us to show do you want us to show your photo album now basil?
Uh, okay, but it's nothing amazing
Okay, so stop downing yourself. I'm sure they'll be great
All right, I'll try to believe myself more
Here this way we can all see
Oh cute
Oh nice, oh read
My is teaching everyone how to make flower crowns. Maureen Kell are holding my example. So pretty
Oh Maureen Kell gave up and ran off but Aubrey and I got the hang of it real fast
Hero's still making his flower crown. It's taking him a little while, but he's getting it
Have to admire his persistence
Oh, this one's cute
Everyone's eating watermelon. So juicy
Aubrey has some seeds on her face
Maybe someone should tell her
Milk oh my gosh, Azura
Azura mention
Kell drinking a bottle of milk his favorite our favorite too, right?
I shouldn't get too close or you might get my camera wet
I and had hero take a picture of us everyone thinks of our crown really suits me
You're all leaning in first mooch
Kell looks so annoyed brotherly love. Oh they're brothers
We're having a big day. All right, you wanted to take a picture of everyone say cheese
After eating everyone fell asleep. That's the link
I prefer vial of the blood whose blood yours, right?
Can I have some mercy milk
How about after stream sound high
I'm getting kind of sleepy myself
Kell said he took a picture of himself on accident, but I don't believe him
I
Have our feet in the circle
Can you guess whose feet or whose?
No, actually no, I'm not that good
Okay, I think that's the entire album
Yep, that's the entire album
These photos are so also charming basil you really know how to capture the moment
Thanks, I didn't take all of them home. I like to steal my camera sometimes
Only sometimes
Hey, I have an idea
Did you all want to come hang out at my house?
I just finished planting some little sprouts and wanted to show everyone
Come on. They're really cute
Yeah, sure that sounds fun. Let's go
It's south of the playground, right? Yep, that's the way
I think I'll sit this one out. Y'all go and enjoy yourselves
But if you ever if you're ever feeling weary, you can always stop by one at one of my picnic
I'll have
some refreshments ready
And you can even save using my picnic basket
Oh, thanks Mari are always doing so much for us
Bye Mari. We'll see you again soon
Run along and have fun now. You know where to find me
Mari's picnic basket. Would you like to sell? Yes, I want to sell
Yeah
Let's look at all these things here
No boss zone violators will be prosecuted
You guys heard that no bosses here
Huh
What happened? Hold on
Why did it die?
I
Why is it doing this?
Okay, it's doing something funky the capture is doing something funky. You guys see that
Senpai, do you see that?
Yeah, we gotta call Netflix. What the heck is going on? What the heck? Hold on
What the heck?
Why is it doing that?
Hmm, let's reset this uh, let's reset this for a second
Maybe I need to make a new uh, capture. Hold on
I'm playing uh, I'll Mari off a PC
I'm playing it off of PC so it shouldn't be doing anything funky
Okay, let's try this and then we'll pull it down
Hopefully this stays I'll get rid of this last capture
I don't know sometimes it does weird things. Oh no, it's still doing it. Why are you doing that?
Why is it doing that?
I'm gonna have to just reset the game
Let's turn let's uh turn it on and off again
That's really weird. I've we've never had it happen before I've never had that happen before
Did a driver issue? I don't think so
Okay, looks normal
Hmm
It's still flickering funky. We'll keep an eye on it. I think
We'll keep an eye on it
I don't know why it's doing this though
Um, the reason why I'm confused about why it's doing this is because it's never done this before
I'm gonna swing to the moon. I tried to do that once
Did the game crash before when I played it it never crashed like this before
So I don't think and uh, I can't do a regular game capture because it's
Chromium based
So I would do a uh window capture instead
So, uh
A window capture is that it captures a specific window
Usually I do a window capture, especially if a game has like a specific cut scene
Uh, because sometimes like uh, when you do a game capture a cut scene
Uh has something in it, uh, that won't get captured
But I am seeing right now that the uh game capture is flickering on in
like
A lot so I'm worried that it's it's going to be really weird because when it captures the screen
There's a yellow border here. Hold on. I'll explain it. There's a yellow border around
the uh the window
if it's uh
If it's capturing it but right now the yellow window like the yellow outlined is uh
Uh flashing so it's making me worried
So that's why I'm just like, hmm, are you gonna be okay?
I wonder if it only happens if I go to this boss thing
Now boss zone
No, I think it's fine
I think it's fine
So that's why oh, yeah, it'll be fine. It'll be fine. Let's check
Early talk so fast when she's excited. It gets really hard to keep up
Nose is my best friend. I can't say much but she's really smart
Nose looks occupied
I like puzzles
I
You'll I hate eggs
Hey, I'm already guess what I got some plans today big plans. Just stay put for a while. You'll see what I mean soon enough
Okay
Okay, same thing
I hate eggs. Hey, wait just one second. Where do you think you're going?
Can't leave without joining us for a game of hide and seek stay and play with us the more the merrier
You you want us you want to play hide and seek again?
But
You know how this turned out last time
Yeah, sorry barely
I think we're gonna have to pass
We're going we're going to basil's house now. So we'll catch up with you later
Not so fast you guys are trying to avoid me again
Oh
What's up with you two is it my face my rough and tough exterior
At least I'm not as bad as boss. It's a good thing. I banned him from the playground after what happened last time
Wonder what that marines up to now
Good riddance
So do you want to play hide and seek basil?
No, either way
There's no rush to get to my house after all
I think I'll leave it up to oh my
What do you want it to?
Oh my
Give me a second
I'm sorry. I'm sorry my best friend. Come on. You know how to play hide and seek. Don't you?
What if I just say no
You don't know how to play hide and seek
What kind of kid are you anyway? That means you have to play with us. I'll explain the rules after I round up everyone
I was forced to do it anyways
Tan hot
All right mega tears the rules
We're gonna be entertaining ourselves with a little game of hide and seek
Here in my hands. I got some straws see everyone's gotta pick a straw
The one with the shortest straw is gonna be it and we'll have to find everyone else
Sounds easy enough, right?
Oh
I'm gonna be the one with the short straw
Y'all got our straws good
Now let's see who's gonna be it
Oh the big guy has has uh
Has candy on his back
Well, well, well looks like the one with the shortest straw is amore
Oh, oh wait amore is it and amore doesn't like to be alone
You're gonna be okay amore
I can take your place if you want. I don't mind really
Hey, I hear you applauding over there. The straws make the rules not me
Come on, don't be babies. It ain't so bad amore will be fine
When you're ready to play walk up to the tether ball pole and close your eyes and no peeking or else
All right
Five four three two one go
Amore amore I'm right here
Oh, you found me. I can help you find everyone else. Just don't tell Burley about this got it
Turns out there's not there's not many places to hide for a guy my size
I
But this was still fun as long as Burley is happy I'm happy
Those goals
Those goals fun goals
Well
We found you button those
No, they found us
No skulls
Oh, you know, I can't stay mad at you. Let's go play patty pick
Darn, hold on
Darn, you found me. I guess that means I lose
You know what happy would say right now
You'd say something like things you should try our best at everything
How else will people see how awesome you are
Next time I guess
Oh
Oh, it's fine
That's me and I was on a private beach servants fanning me on palm tree leaves on every side
And suddenly
Wow
And now here I am
Let's have fallen asleep while hiding. I guess that's game over for me
Oh
You found me Darn
Let's go find everyone else. Okay. Oh my well together. I'm sorry
Are they gonna be in this area
Don't be cheaters
Oh
Hey guys, you know, I found a really good hiding spot
Sean and ran
I didn't mean to join them in there
exercise routine
It's fun
Good for you
Guys should really try this. It's uh, really
A workout
Oh, man. I
So tired
Wow
Oh, you don't know how to say none anyone do you hero?
Come on hero. We gotta help him or you find everyone else
All right. All right
I'm coming
Hi Sean
Yeah, let's do it again sometimes
Oh
They didn't leave do they yo-yo yo-yo
It's a suspicious blue mailbox
Probably should stir this
Okay
They didn't leave did they burly didn't burly didn't leave did he
Can't leave yet
I don't know different voice. Wow
Hey mercy do any yoyo tricks. I used to really love doing the yoyo
Uh, but the only thing I could do was walk the dog
That was it
You can't leave yet. I'm sorry. We haven't even one yet
As long as burly is happy, I'm happy
Allen feels nice here
Yeah
You found me
I swear what's wrong with this fish's blue mailbox
wait a second somebody's got a straw out in here
is this straw on the ground?
pull it out
took you guys long enough
I thought I was gonna suffocate in there
how'd you like my hiding spot?
pretty good eh?
looks like you guys pretty much found everyone else too
unexpected
I like it
let's go for a, let's do a final roll call
can hunt
look at hell
man
here's everyone's van again
here's always buddy
what gives?
happy
here, here
frowns
frowns my new oshi
mods
cut off their testicles
lol
thanks
fun
what is here?
nose, nose curls
Present.
What is it?
Kill.
Yawn.
You really gotta do this every time, barely.
Hey, that wasn't cool!
Aubrey!
Here I am.
Huh? You're spacial.
That's... that's strange.
I thought I saw him go hiding near that tree over there.
Basel, where are you?
Can you hear us?
Basel?
Come out now!
You already won!
Hello, Basel!
Huh?
Hey, there's Basel.
Basel, are you okay?
Are... are you stuck?
Boss, I sure didn't know it was you!
You're good for nothing scoundrel!
Let Basel go!
Yeah, what did Basel ever do to you?
Basel's our friend!
Don't you dare hurt him!
I called Basel, boss.
He didn't do anything wrong.
Whee!
Hehehehe!
You stupid heads!
You think this is about Basel?
I did a really cute voice for Boss.
Don't play dumb!
You know why I'm here!
How dare you not invite me to hide and seek!
I'm the one who showed you all how to play in the first place!
You're not even playing here, right?
How can you call it hide and seek without any body slamming?
My flower crown!
Hey, that's the flower crown we made for Basel!
How could you?
Let go of him, you bully!
No!
If I can't play with everyone, then no one can!
This is a boss-only zone now!
And you're not invited!
Alright!
Where's my skill?
Sad follow-up!
Sure.
Oh, Aubrey do!
Skill.
Peptoc.
Here, let's do it for him.
Oh, Cal-do.
And no one.
You saw him!
Never mind.
Actually.
Attack.
Boss.
Oh, Hero-do.
No, Cook.
Ah, just attack.
Oh, Maury, you had a sad poem.
Oh, Maury felt sad.
Boss attacks.
You can do it, Aubrey!
Cheers on Hero!
You feel happy!
Hero attacks Boss.
Take 15 damage.
Oscar cracks his neck while Maury and friends do fight.
It's a boy.
Oh, we got nothing.
Maury attacks.
Takes 20 damage.
You weaklings!
You call that an attack?
Hero attacks Boss.
Boss takes 15 damage.
Aubrey attacks Boss.
Boss takes 17 damage.
Hero attacks Boss.
Takes 13 damage.
Oscar cracks his neck while friends do fight.
There we go.
Let's keep going.
Hey, that kind of hurt!
Oof!
This isn't fun anymore!
Now you've made me angry!
It's time for my special move!
Bloody slam!
Hero took that damage, became toast.
Aw, we all became toast.
Okay.
Maury did not succumb.
Huh?
How are you still moving?
Yeah.
Maury's party was victorious!
Yay!
He gained 32 AXP.
You got 22 clams.
Wow, we just robbed this kid too!
This isn't fair!
Rematch!
I want a rematch!
Hey, so are you hurt?
I'm not worrying about me.
I'm just fine.
Boss, it must hurt to see people having fun without you.
That doesn't mean you can ruin other people's fun.
Um, I know that.
There.
Does that feel better?
Hey, so are you sure it's okay to do that?
Boss is bad news!
It's a good thing Maury held on during the final attack or else we would have all been toast!
It's okay.
I trust him.
When you were all fighting, you tried really hard to make sure I didn't get hurt.
Is that true, boss?
I'm not sure.
That's a lot of baloney.
I don't need to hear these lies.
This is my spot!
No one is welcome here!
Well, you probably won't be a problem as long as it stays like that.
I guess that means we can go to Basil's house now.
That sounds good to me.
We're leaving now, boss.
Don't cause any trouble, okay?
Okay, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Well, let's check in on Boss.
Aw, okay.
You're gonna swing me in the moon.
Come on, man, put your head in it!
I like puzzles.
I don't like if flowers is someone, but he's only interested in puzzles.
I don't like if I find a flower puzzle or something.
Maybe he would notice me.
Oh.
I might need to make more tea soon.
Come on, controls!
Controls, please let me talk!
Oh, friends.
The grass feels nice here.
Wanna join us, Mari?
Yeah.
The stars shine brightly overhead.
You don't have a care in the world.
What's my favorite tea currently?
My favorite tea is...
Peppermint vanilla.
Very nice.
Mari learned.
Observe.
Thanks, perfect nice for stargazing.
Banana.
Let me touch the banana.
Eternal banana.
Yes, yes.
Hello, valued customer.
Welcome to my shop.
Please buy something.
Candy.
A child's favorite food.
Sweet.
Yoast 30 heart.
Apple juice.
Apparently better than orange juice.
Yoast 25 juice.
Jax, Yoast is small damage to offals and reduces their speed.
Crescent is not what you wanted and flicks anger on a friend or a foal.
I guess I can buy some apple juice.
I'll buy apple juice.
Thank you kindly.
Candy.
And I think I have enough for Jax as well.
There you go.
Whatever.
Did you see the shippity guitar I see made?
Yeah, I did.
It was cute.
Hop.
And a hop.
Having fun takes too much effort to watch my friends have fun is enough for me.
Peek-a-boo.
I like puzzles.
Come on, man.
Put your head into it.
No, this isn't my best friend.
She can't say much, but she's really smart.
No, this looks occupied.
Okay.
Hey, Mori.
How are you all doing?
Just the other day, Noelle was telling me about a cute little leaf she met.
But she tried to be its friend and all I wanted to talk about was how much it hated bunnies.
How could someone hate bunnies?
I just don't understand some people.
Yes, some nutritious candy.
Do you like to eat some?
You and your friend feel alike now.
You want to have a picnic with your friends?
No.
Not yet.
Train station.
Can you move forward?
It's Basel's house.
Maybe we should go to Basel's first?
Okay.
Basel's house.
Maybe we should go to Basel's first?
Oh.
Watering can.
These are sunflowers.
I call that because they always face towards the sun.
That's how I want to be like.
Someone who can always see.
Someone who always sees the bright side of things.
Watering can.
These flowers are called the Lillian of the Valley.
It's said that they're able to ward off evil spirit and help people see a brighter future.
I guess that's why they remind me of mine.
I can always count on her to help me stay positive.
What is that?
Whoa!
What's that ugly plant creature?
Don't you know, Cal?
That's a sprout mole.
Sprout moles are highly intelligent creatures.
They also become dangerously vicious when they are lost.
Please, Mr. Sprout Mole, stop that.
You're stopping all over the flowers.
It looks like the sprout mole is angry.
Like us, sprout moles can also feel emotions.
If the sprout mole is angry, its attack is higher.
On the other hand, its lower, its defense.
Well, what you're saying is now is the perfect time to strike.
Come on, Amore. Let's do this.
Why not?
We're just gonna kick its ass.
Oh.
Okay, that wasn't bad.
You gained 22 EXP, got three clams.
You found tofu.
Amore grew to level two.
Most of the flowers are unharmed.
That's a relief.
Hey, Amore.
We're getting into the hang of battle.
Here's a journal where we can keep track of any neat foals we come across.
Nero gave you the full facts journal.
There, now it's in your pocket.
The journal is yours to record with.
Oh, we might pitch in sometimes too.
Check it out through your pocket or in the player menu by the pressing B.
By pressing B.
Alright.
Okay.
Important.
Full facts.
Views.
A sprout mole.
A dangerous and hostile, ugly plant creature.
It says it's smart, but they do not believe it is.
But do not believe it is not.
It smells like dirty laundry.
Amore.
Alright.
Another one!
Oh no, not again.
Please, Mr. Sprout, don't stop twirling.
You're destroying all of the flowers.
Oh, I see.
This sprout mole is happy.
In that case, it has a higher chance to hit our weak spots and do more damage.
This also means it has a high chance of missing.
Oh.
Amore's party was victorious.
You got four clams, bountiful.
Oh, sorry.
I'm going to just adjust some stuff.
Hmm.
You seem to be running a lot of foals with emotion.
In case you didn't know, emotions can determine how strong or weak the attack is.
Happy beats angry.
Angry beats sad.
And sad beats happy.
That's depressing!
Here, I even drew up a guide on how it works.
I'm no artist, but I think it will get to the point.
I'll put it in your pocket so you can check it out later.
Got a motion chart.
You want to look at that motion chart now?
Yeah.
Oh wait, that's cute.
Sad, defense up speed town.
Some damage to heart becomes juice.
Angry equals attack up and defense down.
Happy is luck up, speed up, and rate down.
Strong to sad and strong to happy.
Happy's weak to strong.
Strong.
Angry is strong to sad and sad is weak to angry.
Happy is strong to angry.
And angry is weak to happy.
And neutral is just in the middle.
Yeah, I'm not an artist, but this is pretty cute, yeah.
I want to look at the other flowers.
These type of flowers are called gladiose.
Gladiose, gladiolus.
Wow, I can't read!
I can't read!
Is the gladiolus what?
Gladiolus, also known as the sword flower.
As you might guess, it represents a strength of character.
A woman who is honest with strong moral values.
Someone who stands by the conviction that gladiolus reminds me of Aubrey
because she's always true to herself.
Oh, I see.
But you're saying that Aubrey is really stubborn!
Hey, no I'm not!
Okay, let's move on.
These are roses.
Can you guess who they remind me of?
They remind me of Hero.
Can you guess correctly?
Roses come in many different colors and have their own unique meanings.
Pink roses represent...
Oh, symbolize is admiration.
Orange roses symbolize passion.
Yellow roses symbolize friendship.
The list goes on.
Hero doesn't remind me of any rose in particular.
Like, heroes like all roses because he's versatile and universally loved.
Oh, that's really sweet.
You got, like, so many, so many flowers based off of your friends.
Whoa, what are these flowers called?
They're all cool and spiky!
I should tell.
This is the cactus.
It's more of a plant than a flower.
It's funny that you ask because they remind you of you.
Is it because he's a prick?
Hey!
Well, not too, but mostly because cactus are very sturdy and resilient plants by nature.
I can't believe!
They were like, yeah, it's because you're a prick.
That too.
They don't need much care and can survive even in seemingly impossible conditions.
Guess what I'm saying is that even you could take care of a cactus, Cal.
Whoa, neat!
Cacti are awesome!
Did not even notice the inson there.
Ah, these are twice tulips.
They are simple and bulbous.
Just like a mori.
Bul- bulb- bulbus?
Bulbas?
Water's off a duck's back?
Exactly like Shibi.
Shibi's, like, so strong.
Everything is water off a duck's back.
I don't know, I just think it's cute.
Oh, Basil, you think I'm cute?
Uh-huh.
Ah, not another sprout, Mo.
Not good, Basil.
We gotta hang him this by now.
Hmm, this sprout mo seemed a bit sad.
See how it's curled up in the fetal position?
That means it won't do as much damage as normal.
But it'll also take less damage to heart and will lose juice instead.
How sad.
Let's put it out of its misery.
Alright?
Hmm.
Okay.
I'm gonna just keep on attacking, whatever.
I'm just like, oh wow, this thing is depressed?
Kill it.
Alright.
Oh, how'd you get here so fast, Mari?
Hi everyone, y'all just came in time for a lovely picnic.
Feel free to rest here.
Everything is already all set up and I even brought some fruit.
Alright.
Let's have a picnic with our friends.
Cute.
Delicious fruit, would you like to eat some?
I mean, your friends feel like new.
Munch, munch, munch, munch.
Whoa, thanks, Mari, you're the best.
Oh, it's nothing.
I'm gonna look out for all of you.
Ah, Mari, I wish it could be more like you.
You always seem to have everything under control.
That's not true at all.
It just seems that way from the outside.
Either way, you sure seem to make everything look easy.
Yes, I agree.
Mari is effortlessly graceful.
Don't you think so, Mari?
Oh, Mari, stop kidding around.
Is there any way to treat your big sister?
I have straight down this way.
Are we all ready to go?
I'm ready when you are.
I'll catch you later, Mari.
Let me know if you need anything.
You soon.
Well, let's see if we can save here.
I want to say no because I was like, nah.
It's the same thing.
Oh, shoot, I'm going the wrong direction.
I wanted to see before we go to Basil's house
if there's anything on the other areas
or if they're just blocked off, too.
Give us a second.
I feel like Basil's house is actually like a final area,
so I'm just going to check.
Mari, we're supposed to go to my house.
Let's just pass the cell.
And let's finish finding some little sprouts
and why don't you show everyone?
Come on, they're really cute.
Transportation station doesn't seem to be in service.
Okay, well, I guess we'll go to your house.
Never mind, I wanted to find the little puzzle,
but okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Get back over here.
Thank you.
Okay, we saved already, so it's fine.
Let's just go.
What is that?
What the hecky-wecky?
What emotion is this feeling, Engie?
What was...
What was this feeling, Engie?
No.
Why do you like major damage?
Help.
Oh.
Yeah.
I really couldn't tell what emotions I was feeling.
Oh man, this fight is pretty tough.
Don't worry, we can do this if we work together.
Looks like I'm going to have to teach you all a little bit about teamwork.
Let's try it again, Amore.
We'll get him this time.
You notice anything different, Amore?
You should see a new bar at the bottom of the screen with the number on the side.
It's our collective energy.
By using our energy, we can beat this ball together.
Just attack and you'll see.
Like this.
It...
Hold on.
You see the bubble that popped up when we attacked?
That's called follow-up.
If you attack for a limited time, you can use energy to perform a follow-up.
Press any direction...
Direction or arrow and see what happens.
Alright?
No, why didn't it work?
Huh.
That cost three energy.
Oh, I see.
Ew.
Man, this guy's really tough.
When you attack this, did you notice that our energy went up?
When we take damage, we can also gain energy.
Think of it as a chance to make a comeback.
Alright.
Okay, so cost three, so that's why they're not...
Okay.
Nice, we're full of energy.
Every time we use our special attack, Mari, after you attack, press to release energy.
Okay, it's the... this button?
Okay.
Up here already?
Come on, everyone.
Show this big guy what we're made of.
Did I do the wrong one?
Oh, I pressed the wrong one.
It was down.
Oops.
I thought when I said press the directional button, I was like, okay, I just pressed the
directional button because it's pressable.
Not bad.
Whatever, I can do it again.
My bad.
That was my bad.
Whatever.
Learn stab him.
Operate group to three, level three.
Hero group to level three, yeah.
And there you have it.
Geralt's battle tutorial 101.
And I'm sure that we fight more battles, our team work will improve over time.
Oh, you guys, that was so amazing.
Yeah, that was nothing.
I could have taken...
I could have taken away better gear guys than that.
I should teach you some of my skills one of those days.
Basil, I know you're not the type that likes to fight, but it's good to know how to defend
yourself, too.
You know, I've actually been working on a book all about battles.
Maybe we can all study together next time.
I'll give it to Omori to hold on for now.
I'm just the pack mule, hey?
Yes, we get stronger, I'll be updating the follow-up section of the self-help guide,
so you should just check it out every now and then.
Omori, you should know when we gain EXP and level up, sometimes we also learn skill.
Skills are powerful and have a wide range of effects, but each of us can only remember
up to four skills at a time.
After you learn a new skill, don't forget to equip it from the player menu, okay?
Yeah, yeah, we know.
We got a Basil's house now.
Okay, that's all I had to say.
Ah, Patience Kale.
Kale?
I'm calling him Kale.
There was an old lady who lived in a shoe.
What was that nursery rhyme again?
I totally forgot.
Hey, cheese!
Hold on, let me look it up.
Let me look it up.
Oh, lady who lived...
Okay.
Okay, let's see.
There was an old woman who lived in a shoe.
She had so many children she didn't know what to do.
She gave them some broth and a big slice of bread.
She kissed them all soundly and sent them to bed.
There you go.
Do you guys know that nursery rhyme?
That's not the version you know.
What version did you have now?
Well, it came out kind of blurry.
Well, it's okay, it gives character.
If you don't mind the photo.
Of course we don't mind, I won't see it.
Oh, sure thing.
Y'all look so cute!
Now's my hair.
I wanna see, I wanna see!
Oh, hey Amari, you wanna look at the photo too?
Yeah, it is blurry.
Whip them all soundly and pop them to bed is the one I know.
Oh, okay, okay, I guess.
Okay, okay, I...
Okay, well that one's a little darker.
I definitely learned the version I just read.
See how it came out kind of blurry?
But you can...
But y'all still look so cute.
I should add it to my collection.
Oh, woohoo, another shot for the full album.
Oh, Wolver, Amari, I can't see.
Hey, stop pushing!
You already had your turn!
Get out of my way, Cal!
Wait, wait, wait, hold on, there's no need to fight.
Me first!
No, me!
Ah, stop it!
You guys are knocking me over.
Uh, oops.
Oh my gosh, Basel!
Basel, we're so sorry!
You okay, Basel?
You two are in big trouble now.
This is why both of you need to learn how to get along.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean it, hero.
Please don't tell Amari.
It's okay, don't worry about it.
Accidents happened.
Here's your photos.
It doesn't look like any of them got damaged.
Let's put them back in your photo album together.
You hero?
Let's go inside my house first.
Remember to wipe your feet before you come in.
Everybody, wipe your feet before you go in, okay?
Wait a second, hold on.
Is there anything around here?
Anything special? No.
Okay, we just go in though.
Wipe your feet!
You guys wiping?
Zephyze, wipe your feet!
Basel's photo album.
It's the most precious belonging.
Are you ready to put the photo?
Put back the photos Amari?
Yeah.
Yeah, let's get started.
I don't think I remember the order of these photos.
No, I'm not a thing, Basel.
Amari has really good memories, I'm sure.
We'll figure this out in no time.
Lies in me!
Oh.
I think it was this one.
Or not, hold on.
Wait, no, I need to put it back!
I wanted to...
Okay.
Is that correct?
Basel's memory.
There, it's new.
Really sorry for pushing you over, Basel.
Even though at least half of it was Kels' fault.
Yeah, I promise.
Never to ever, to never fall for it.
I'm sorry.
Ever, to never fight with Aubrey ever again, unless she starts this first.
No worry about it.
I know you only wanted to see my photo album.
Thank you for helping me put it back together.
That's strange.
Photo must have been loose.
Huh? What's this?
Can I take this photo?
Something about it seems...
...well familiar.
No, no.
I can't be.
My face!
Huh?
Meow?
What do you do around here, is there?
Get you a box for wiping your sorrows away.
Your sketchbook.
Take a look inside.
You only got...
Oh, what the heck is that? That's new.
You booted up your laptop.
What'd you like to do?
Look at your screen.
Let's share it at the screen.
In your journal.
Everything? Okay.
The heat from the laptop warmed your lap.
It felt nice.
Meow?
Meow? Or is there?
For a way out?
There's one.
But...
Meow? Waiting for something to happen?
Light bulb hangs from the ceiling.
Wherever it is.
Looking for light bulb?
It's black inside.
You can't see a thing.
Cow!
Oh, what?
Cat?
What do you say?
Something you do?
I would just ignore it.
But...
when all those red things, they're like cans
and it brings you back to the beginning.
Oh, there's more of them.
I can't remember.
Oh, there's more.
Huh.
Kat, tell me what the fuck I need to do.
What's my charm?
What do I need to like?
Never mind.
There's a stab one here.
Dab? Who? Stab me?
Okay.
Ow.
Are you gonna take it? Yeah?
Look at all of us.
There are all our memories together.
They're a little sad now.
But we should be happy that they happened at all.
Oh, Zerah's in chat?
Let's make some new memories together, okay?
You see a boy sleeping in his room.
What's his name?
You guys want to be sunny?
I guess we got a default name.
Or should I go for a regular?
Regular name. You guys want to be...
Does my senpai want to be...
You want to be senpai? Okay.
That's uppercase senpai.
The boy's name is senpai?
Yeah.
Hey senpai, it's mommy.
I'm still in the city setting things up for our new home.
Did you finish packing yet?
Movers are going to be at our house in a few days,
so I left a list of things for you to do before they arrive.
Oh, so sorry. Mommy messed up.
I forgot to tell you the electric company
that we need a few extra days before we're ready to move,
so the lights might be cut out sometime tonight.
Anyway, I know moving to a new place can be a little nerve-wracking right now,
but I think a change of scenery will be positive for both of us.
I know you haven't talked to anyone in a while,
but you might want to say goodbye to your old friends before we leave.
How's it going to have... has been really...
I've been really... that's what I can't read right now.
How's it been trying really hard to get ahold of you
ever since we put our house up for sale?
He's been calling us every week for the past few months.
He seems a little lonely.
Maybe he should pay him a visit.
Okay, that's it for now.
Mommy loves you. Bye, honey.
Zzz.
You are hungry.
An old computer.
A bunch of books.
Cardboard boxes littered across the house.
Or a drope.
An ordinary house plan. Nothing special about it.
Table lamp.
Mums, do you know- Hi senpai, this is a note from mommy.
I left some food in this fridge for you downstairs.
It's steak, your favorite.
Love you!
Hugs and kisses.
Mums, to-do list.
I don't feel like doing chores right now.
A bathtub.
It's me.
Hi senpai, this is a note from mommy.
Remember to brush your teeth every day.
Love you!
Hugs and kisses.
Towels and toiletries.
Toilet.
Haha, it's shibby!
I mean-
She's gonna fucking kill me.
No, don't tell Ezra!
Are you not here for me for a few days?
Yeah.
I'm trapped in Wonderland, okay?
Hahaha!
This is ma, a big houseland.
One of two old grandfather couples.
They stopped working a long time ago, but mom likes to keep them around.
What case has been cleared out?
A nary houseplant.
Nothing special, wow.
About it.
Yeah!
Yeah, I feel like shibby is gonna kill me.
She's gonna fucking murder me.
I mean, I'll hear me for a week.
You know why?
I'll come back, though.
I'll just get, I'll get Emmy to bring me back.
I'll get Emmy to bring me back.
That's no problem.
Carver box is littered across the house.
This empty picnic basket.
Would you like to save?
Yeah.
Oh, now I'm colored in.
Some family photos.
Carver boxes are littered across the house.
Mom said, the mattress is too hard for you to sleep comfortably.
It's fine, it's fine.
Probably.
Are you sure you want to go downstairs?
What do you mean, are you sure?
I checked everything up here, right?
No?
Is there things I didn't see?
Okay, well, sure, whatever.
What, no?
Why not?
Ah, metal!
Metal!
Metal's ringing!
Hi Raiders, welcome!
Welcome to the stream!
Metal, metal, metal, metal, metal, metal, metal!
Welcome, metal!
Welcome, metal, from UMAP Plus!
Welcome to the stream!
Wow, have you guys checked out metal yet?
UMAP Plus girls are so cute.
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute.
Welcome Raiders!
Hello Raiders!
Welcome to the stream!
I'm playing Amore right now.
My name is MercyModees from VLRs.
Gen 1 Indulge!
Welcome to the stream!
I really appreciate Metal bringing you in.
Meryl, what did you play?
Or what did you do?
I'm so glad, thank you!
I played Zero Escape.
Oh my gosh, I love the Nonary series.
I'm bad at numbers, but I love the Nonary series.
When I first got nine persons, nine doors, nine hours,
I don't remember the order it was in.
I literally thought I only had nine hours to complete it.
So I was like putting it off for a while.
Turns out, you know, that's just the story
and I didn't actually need only nine hours to play
when I played it on DS.
I got it gifted by a friend.
That's like, oh no!
Oh my gosh, I thought, oh my god, no,
I thought the escape parts were time to nine,
but it's two, me too!
Me too, I thought, I thought I only had nine,
like literally nine hours to just do it.
So it was rough.
It was rough times.
But yeah, I'm glad, I'm glad.
Are you pretty far into it?
It's such a fun game.
I've completed the entire series,
so I don't think I'll stream it.
But if you guys want to check out the Nonary's Zero Escape,
check out Merrill playing it.
It's probably fun.
It's probably lots of fun.
I think it's lots of fun.
I said probably because I was nervous,
some pies would be like, oh, I don't know.
Puzzle games, that's not my thing.
But guess what? Puzzle games are my thing.
I'm a second game now.
It's been big fun so far.
Yeah!
Did you stream the first game too?
I'm sure people would love to see a lot of it.
Mercy, have you played Ibb?
Yeah, I played Ibb.
Not the new one, where they extended a lot of stuff,
but like the old one.
When it was free.
When Ibb was free, I played it when it was free.
Like a long, long time ago.
I did, yeah, I finished the first one on stream.
Yeah, everybody go check that out, okay?
Check out the first one,
and then check out the playthrough for Merrill's one.
Yeah, I love puzzle games.
It's so fun.
Thank you so much for the raid once again.
I really appreciate it.
Right now, we gotta figure out
how to go down the stairs.
I have some studying to do.
I'll be looking to have a big fun stream, Mercy.
Okay, good luck with your study.
Work hard and get those grades up.
A plus all around.
Wee!
And now the rest of you are with me.
Yeah, I'm winking, but you can't tell
because I am wearing an eye patch.
So let's continue.
So, can I not go downstairs?
Hmm.
Isn't the beach this bathtub?
I feel like I literally have gone through everything.
Why not?
Get your ass down there.
Close your eyes.
You feel dizzy.
Maybe you can sleep it off.
No, go downstairs.
Okay, fine.
Fine, fine.
We'll go back to bed.
A little.
Now, I guess I have to go to sleep.
No, you definitely are hungry.
Get the fuck out of bed.
You've a glowing light, what?
Oh, look!
Senpai, do you need a hand?
Are stairs always as steep?
Well, maybe if you're scared of them.
No, you can do it.
That's a real hand!
That's a real hand.
Go away, go away, go away.
Okay.
What will Senpai do?
Senpai, what are you going to do?
Something.
Can I run?
Can I only fight?
Okay.
No.
Senpai.
Take a deep breath.
Don't be afraid.
It's not as scary as you think.
You steady yourself.
Remember how to calm down.
I'm still sick, man.
Oh, we made it down the stairs.
Woo!
Well, it's fine.
Think of me to calm down, Senpai.
You were thinking about me, right?
You got a first aid kit.
The case has been cleared out.
Why not?
Okay, well, let's...
No.
Look in the fridge and found cold steak.
Take it.
You got cold steak.
Probably should heat it up before you eat it.
I'll grab the knife after.
The cold steak in the microwave.
You got microwave steak.
Where's my steak?
You pick up the steak knife.
Yes, a lovingly well done steak.
Would you like to eat something?
Yeah.
What's Chat's favorite...
I'm not Chat, sorry.
Oh, have it die hard.
Senpai, what's your favorite food?
Actually, I already know, but...
Your stomach didn't agree with that.
Well, time to find the toilet.
That was mom's room.
Bathroom is this one.
Time to barf.
Bleurgh.
Mercy lemonade?
What?
Mercy lemonade is what?
Let's see.
Icy lemonade!
Where are you guys?
Where's Senpai's getting these lemonades from?
Yeah, yeah, it's a drink.
Not food, but I mean, I guess if it's your favorite,
I can treat you to more.
The air-cooler lemonade stand.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
What's the price for lemonade nowadays?
It used to be 25 cents for a cup back in...
back in the old days.
I prefer milk.
Azura.
Okay, we can sell milk on the side too.
This is a startup.
We're gonna do a violour lemonade stand.
So, milk costs maybe like...
How much does milk cost nowadays?
I usually leave the shop into mama.
Mama and papa.
Milk spoil is easy though.
Okay, well maybe we can do like...
like, you know, we take that milk
and then we make it into ice cream with the lemonade.
So then we have like a lemonade swirl.
Yeah?
And then we package it.
Now we package it.
Now we package it and then we sell it at the...
at the lemonade stand.
We'll run it illegally of course.
We won't get a business license.
Self-squeezed.
Oh my gosh.
Azura, Azura should definitely...
should definitely like be the brains of this operation.
Freshly, fresh milk...
Fresh milk with every pop.
I can't even mimic Azura's voice.
Fresh milk with every drop.
Azura's so much better.
I'm not as good as Sheeby when it comes to like voice impersonations.
Yes, we all want Azura's milks.
Azura could probably crash the milk market.
Yeah.
I swear if Azura like came...
Simpa, you know the mega milk shirt?
Like, I feel like, you know, Azura would like be...
you know, ultra milk or something.
Mercy milk would be competitor?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You haven't tried warm, delicious Azura milk yet.
Okay?
So everyone, we're going to...
Simpa, we're going to pitch this idea to Strony.
It's going to be a new business venture and we're going to make millions.
Okay? We're going to be millionaires.
Have you tried warm, delicious Azura milk?
Of course.
Everyone in Bielor has.
Hahaha.
Can we get GamerSup's cup with you guys on it?
Well, I don't know.
You'll have to probably pass that idea on to Strony
or I don't know, harass GamerSup.
No, actually do not harass GamerSup's for it.
That was a joke.
That's a joke, but like, you know, that's a joke.
I promise that part was a joke.
If anyone does it, I relinquish all responsibility for that.
Thank you.
No, no, no, no, no, do it.
But yeah, everyone in Bielor has tried...
Azura milk.
And I think everyone should too, especially if you're a bleeding heart.
I know. Is it bleeding heart?
Oh, I'm so bad. I'm forgetting fan names.
Yeah, it's bleeding hearts.
Okay, whoo.
Whoo, whoo, whoo.
I was like, am I mismer... remembering things?
Well, we'll bring this, we'll make millions, millions.
If I get into Gen 2, can we get Azura milk?
Of course, only if you get into Gen 2.
But first, pay attention to Gen 1.
Us, okay? Us.
We just came out, come on, you already want the next big thing?
I'll fucking kill you.
Oh, sorry, that sounded more like Serani.
Okay?
I'll kill you.
And then...
there won't be a Senpai anymore.
So pay attention to us.
First.
Enjoy us, what do we... when we can.
But what if I like being stabbed?
Then you won't get stabbed, easy peasy, right?
Isn't that punishment enough?
So, be good. Be good.
Let's...
We'll cross the bridge when we get there.
Right now, you have to pay attention to me.
Azura.
Chibi.
Icy.
Emi.
Stroni.
Understudi.
I'm sorry.
Good.
Good Senpai.
Good boys and good girls.
I'm glad we have our understanding.
How could you talk about anyone else?
Even a figurative anyone else.
You need us right now.
That's all you need right now is us.
So, no more of that.
We'll cross that bridge when we get there.
And that's not for at least another year.
So, shh.
Shhh.
Good.
I'm good.
Good Senpai.
You're so kind and trusting.
I knew you would understand.
Alright.
So we just threw up.
You threw up.
Yep.
Thought so.
Hahaha.
Can we flush it?
I threw up.
Mom, I threw up.
Hahaha.
Stanny.
Imagine standing outside of Adrien's garden.
Mom, me?
I threw up.
Wait, what?
No, let me back down!
What the heck?
Hey.
Hey Senpai, it's Mari.
Hahaha.
I'm finally back home, but I forgot my keys.
Could you open the door for me?
Yeah, sure!
Open the door!
Stop having it be closed.
Hahaha.
Oops.
Spooky.
Did we hear something else?
Something.
Maybe it's the bathroom?
Alright, I guess we gotta look in the mirror.
Right?
Senpai?
Ooh, spooky!
Nope, not there anymore.
Spooky?
Did your heart race a little bit?
It only races for mercy.
Oh, you!
My Senpais are so kind to me.
I knew everyone loved me.
Do we go to sleep now?
Yeah, we'll go to sleep.
Why is Senpai's mom so absent?
Mom went out to the city to check out the new house.
Welcome to white space.
You've been living here as long as you can remember.
Meow, waiting for something to happen?
Tissue box for wiping your sorrows away.
Is something gonna update now?
Okay, so now I know at least this is a steak.
A steak.
Collect keys.
What's this?
In the grass near a stump on a shrouded old bridge
between giant pinwheels near a cast-off cartridge
underneath a wet pillow within a large flame
beneath a trapped door lost in Pyre's flame
lying in a dark cell trapped in a pink cage
in a hall of framed faces far below a big stage.
Spending time with a frog near a game of roulette
amongst the other owls in a water closet
in a small moving room at the end of the plank
within a live shell in a large bubbly tank
surrounded by goo captured in a steel trap
the gut of a whale at the end of a map
in the field of white snow past the end of the road.
Okay.
Is that my stomach?
Something found nearby.
What's this?
You found a map.
Okay.
Press right button to open the headspace map.
Like that. Okay.
And then we can just open this up.
Okay, to collect things.
Okay, we have that now.
Okay.
That was a pretty heavy map, yeah.
Hey, Doorcast, if you'd like to do,
we should open the door.
Yeah, we should open the door.
Okay.
No.
Mari, thank goodness you're here.
Have you seen Basil?
I can't find him anywhere.
We should, we should go tell Mari you're okay.
Oh my goodness.
Ooh.
Will Senpai allow me a bit of time to make another tea?
Of course you will. You have no choice.
Senpais always want me in best health, right?
Okay, I'm going to go make some tea so that I,
I'm out of liquid right now.
Can we get tea too? Of course.
I'll tell you what tea I make this time, okay?
Thank you.
I'll be right back. I'm going to just make a tea.
Okay.
Senpai, what are you doing?
What are you doing? What have you done?
Spill it.
Drop what's, whatever's in your mouth.
Open.
Nothing, nothing.
Took you long enough.
Hi.
Okay.
I may have accidentally boiled the water a little too full,
so I had to clean that up a little bit.
Uh-huh.
You were just cleaning, huh?
What were you cleaning?
What mess did I leave out?
What mess did you leave out?
No ping pong.
You were playing ping pong?
Without me?
Senpai.
Senpai, how could you?
Anyways, today's...
Anyways, to, right now, the tea that I decided to go with is echinacea.
Echinacea tea.
Same one that I always do.
You brought a pool table to everybody into the cage.
Back again.
Everyone.
Where the universal, universal shock collar that we all got from Shibi.
And we're putting the shock collar to 10.
Bzzzzz.
Now, everybody's shocked.
Since when were there shock callers in Wonderland?
Since forever.
I mean, like, that place is full of toys everywhere.
Come on.
Hey, yeah, I get some of my stuff with them.
You bring tea for the rest of us?
You didn't ask me to bring you back tea, Senpai.
You want me to make you a cup all over again?
I'm still waiting for this one to cool.
We did ask, though.
Oh, did you?
I must have not heard.
I'll make everyone a little cup later.
Is Echinacea OK?
Anything.
OK.
I'll boil up a teapot.
I'll bring out the finest teapot.
I'll bring out the finest teapot and the finest china there is.
There'll be, like, little cats on them or something.
Actually, I do have a cat one.
Yeah, I have a really cute cat one.
We want to hear our cup.
There are six.
Fight for them.
Mercy lemonade.
You've been bad.
Why would I give you that?
I also don't have lemons with me, so you have to wait a few days.
You have to wait a few days, and I'll come back with the lemonade.
And then, yeah, it'll be fine.
Well, let's continue, since you've all been so bad.
Are lemons even in season?
Good question.
Maybe I'll get, like, those lemon zest, and then we'll sprinkle it.
We'll put some a little bit into water.
And then maybe, maybe we'll dilute it, and then no one will notice.
No one will notice at that point.
You should go tell Mara you're okay.
She's worried sick.
Oh, am I stuck out of the window?
There we go.
I'm still going to let the tea cool a bit, though.
But thank you, senpai.
Stretch.
Okay, we should go tell Mara you're okay.
Just give me a second.
Okay.
We should go tell Mara you're okay.
Just give me a second.
We should tell Mara you're okay.
She's been worried sick.
I don't know, glies.
Let's get this toaster.
Toast.
It's going out all night.
Here's your allowance for today.
I got 200 clams.
I got 200 clams!
They said there was one.
Hold on.
In the grass near a stump.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Hey.
11 keys left.
I'll build a sand castle again.
Okay, let's see.
Next one on a shrouded old bridge.
I'm not sure if this is the bridge.
And there's like a bunch of A's at the end.
Hmm.
I'm lying.
You're okay.
Don't worry.
Don't worry me like that.
Where's Basil?
He's not with you, Maury?
No.
I'm afraid not.
The last thing I remember was sorting photos with Basil in his house.
Next thing I know.
I'm waking up in neighbor's room with Aubrey and Cal.
Ah.
At least we found you, Maury.
I hope Basil's okay.
He's gonna protect him if we're not there.
We'll be such a downer, Aubrey.
We'll find Basil for sure.
Absolutely right, Cal.
It's times like this we got to stay positive.
I only go back to Basil's house.
Might be something we missed.
That's the spirit hero.
He's always up here if you need me.
Merci.
May I ask what the guidelines are on Villalor fan video games?
I don't see anything about on the Villalor website.
Hmm.
Is it not on the terms of service?
Not terms of service, the fan work guidelines?
Oops.
Hold on.
Let me put this down a little bit.
I'm a controller.
Right now my lips are a little dry,
so I'm gonna have to put lip balm on.
But I don't think there's anything against it,
but you'll probably have to ask Stronny for management for that.
Or I'll send in an email through the website.
I'm not like a reliable source.
How's the tea, Mercy?
I can't taste it because...
because it's too hot.
Still.
I'm sure we're more than happy to get a fan game.
But I'm pretty sure it's under, like, fan work?
Fan work derivatives or something?
Just double check it.
All fan arts, of course, need to comply with the...
with the...
Oops.
Ooh.
I'm knocking things over.
With the terms of services?
Yeah.
Sorry, just put on a lip balm.
Ah, my lips get so dry.
It's been so cold lately.
Yeah, that's good tea.
Okay.
Let's continue.
I struggle with dry lips myself.
Uh, never seems to help.
Okay.
Um, I have this trouble, too.
So the only thing that works for me are two...
are three things.
Um...
Vaseline.
Um, the specific lip gloss.
And...
Okay, this is gonna sound really weird.
But this is a suggestion a lot of celebrities do.
Which is nipple cream.
Uh, nipple balm.
Sorry, not nipple cream.
Nipple balm.
Because, uh, it's for...
for, um...
for mothers.
When a child is feeding...
feeding, um, the balm...
the nipple can get really chapped and dry.
And because the...
the, um...
the texture on the nipple is similar to lips.
I guess.
Um, a lot of celebrities use a...
nipple balm...
for their lips instead.
Yeah, it hurts.
It hurts.
So, like, a lot of mothers will buy these nipple balms,
and then they'll...
they'll, uh, it helps with the...
the peeling and the dryness and the pain
and the sores from...
from when a baby, uh...
baby, uh, suckles.
Yeah.
Actually, you can literally probably go to any store
and then they'll have it.
They'll probably have it.
Uh, I bought some.
I bought some not too long ago
because I had, like, really dry lips.
Um, a lot of people say, uh,
it lasts quite a long time.
You only need a little bit.
And I find that it doesn't dr...
it doesn't go away as fast as the, um...
as regular lip balm.
It doesn't work for me, though,
because I kind of have sensitive skin,
so if it gets anywhere around the lip area,
that's not on my lips.
And it tends to, like, uh, that area
tends to be, like, a little sensitive.
So, um, let me...
Okay, I know it's weird,
but let me find...
find, uh, it.
I know it's weird.
It's weird.
It's weird, but I want to help.
So, this is the one...
I have.
Let me try to find it.
Here.
Um...
I'll show you.
It does say cream on it,
but it's more like a balm.
It's more like a balm.
It comes out like a Vaseline balm.
It-a-ba-ba-ba-ba-neep balm cream.
My skin's kind of sensitive,
so it doesn't really work
for the skin around it,
but this is what I...
I don't know.
It doesn't work the skin around it,
but this is what I-I found to work.
This-this one.
Does it smell?
I don't think it has a particular smell to it,
especially because it's, uh,
safe for babies to ingest as well,
so I think it doesn't have
any particular smell to it.
So a lot of celebrities
will use this instead of
a regular lip balm
because it's stronger.
I think it comes in a-a different format now.
I think it comes in a little jar.
Jar, but when I bought it,
it-it's-it's this-it's this little tube.
But yeah, this is, like,
if you have trouble finding lip balm,
so, like, if regular lip balm doesn't work for you
and, like, Vaseline doesn't work for you
or anything, try this one.
Try this.
Like, legitimately, it-it-it will help with, uh,
try it out.
It's not too expensive either, I think.
Uh, and it lasts forever.
It lasts forever.
How much per box?
I bought it for around ten-
I bought it for ten dollars,
and it's a huge little tube, you know?
It's about-it was about the size of my hand,
but then again, my hands are-are a bit-
or maybe different size.
I'm not sure.
I think it might be cheaper at certain places,
but it's definitely something that-that people can use
for their lips.
For their lips instead of, um,
instead of regular lip balm.
Especially if it, uh...
If it, if it, if it...
Because, uh, let's be real,
lip balm industry kind of sucks.
They literally dry out your lips even more
and so that you have to reapply it all the time.
Kind of sucks that way.
So, yeah, celebrities will use, uh, this little-
for this-for lip balm instead.
And since it's, uh, safe for babies to ingest,
it should be safe on your lips
and for you to ingest as well.
So, um...
Yeah, the brand I use normally
that doesn't make my skin super sensitive,
is if you have super sensitive skin,
uh, the nipple-nipple cream might not work for you,
so I just use Vaseline.
I just use Vaseline.
It works.
Does-but does nipple balm come in a nice little container
that fits also nicely in my pocket?
Um, my advice for that is take a lip balm tin,
like an empty lip balm tin,
and just squeeze some in.
Vaseline's the only thing that works for me.
It's really s-it's-it's petroleum, so...
Um, but, uh, I find the nipple-the nipple balm,
like, it's-it's about the size of my hand.
It actually fits in, like, purse and stuff really well.
And if-well, if you're-you're a guy,
you have pockets everywhere, it's gonna fit.
Your pockets can fit in ten-Nintendo switches,
so it's fine.
But, like, if you have sensitive skin,
um, try it out first.
Like, try-it might work out for you.
It didn't work for me,
but I do use it in emergencies.
Like, if my skin-my lip-the skin on my lip
is so chapped it's, like, cutting,
I will use the nipple balm.
Cause, um, yeah, I suffer from-from dry skin,
sensitive skin, mostly dry skin.
My skin is super dry, so I need to moisturize a lot.
Wait, Mercy, you can have a lip balm ASMR trigger.
What does that mean?
How do you do that?
Thanks, Mercy.
This has been extremely educational.
Finally, some-maybe, finally,
can get some soft lip-sci-cave.
Yeah.
Just dry skin or eczema.
I don't have eczema, but I do have dry skin.
Pretty dry skin, so my skin will get pretty flaky and stuff.
That being-that was, like, what?
Like, popping the lips like this?
Like, like that?
Is-is that a trigger?
Really?
What?
It is?
Oh, okay.
Thanks for teaching me some pie.
But yeah, I suffer from dry lips,
so every once in a while during streams,
I'll be like, uggh, if you see me go like,
uggh, I'm gonna go like,
uggh, if you see me go like, uggh,
I'm putting on the bomb.
Yeah, mercy my twin with the skin issues.
But yeah, if-if-if everyone,
if, like, Senpai suffer from dry lips,
I have, like, tips-
I have tips, so I have, like,
I definitely use that one.
Vaseline is my only go-to recently.
Um...
And then, for Vaseline,
I just put it in, like, a little tin.
You can also probably do the same thing.
Wanted. What's the Wanted poster?
Pluto, the ninth planet in the solar system.
No reward, sorry.
Huh?
Faceless Missy.
Huh? Faceless Missy again?
It wasn't me this time, I promise.
I'll leave me alone to repent.
I'm gonna swing in the moon!
Eh? There's a mirror here.
A floating mirror.
Your friends smile warmly behind you.
That-that's cute.
I think it flowers someone,
but he's only interested in puzzles.
If only I had a-
I could find a flower puzzle or something.
He would notice me.
I wonder if there's a flower puzzle or something.
How about you?
Huh?
Oh, I'm glad I could help my supplies.
I know it's a weird-
I know it's weird, especially if it's like-
Hey, so, it's got to be around here somewhere.
Especially since it's like,
Oh, Violaur, the, uh, the,
Hoo-hoo, company.
Kind of sus company.
Oh no, a flower!
It's flowers! They're already dying!
Do your best to take care of them until Basel gets back.
Would you like to water the plants?
Yeah, of course!
Oh!
How do I...
How do I water them?
Wait, how do I water them?
Is water the voted ones?
Okay.
Well, these are lilies of the valley, so they probably just look like that, huh?
Okay, well...
Cacti probably won't die.
Tulips are fine.
Ma, are you here?
Get some delicious fruits?
Cacti probably won't die.
Wipe your feet, everyone!
Ugh, fuck are you!
Oh, there doesn't seem anything out of the ordinary.
You think Basel just left somewhere without telling us?
I don't know, that doesn't sound like him.
He's usually so considerate about these things.
Guys, I'm really worried. There's nothing we can do?
We can't find him!
What if he's in danger?
They come, Aubrey.
I'm worried too, but that won't solve anything.
He won't slug around the forest.
Maybe he wandered off and got lost.
Yeah, cheer up, Aubrey!
We'll find Basel.
You guys are right.
Okay, we gotta keep our hopes up.
Let's look for Basel in the Vast for it.
What is that?
Fireplace is burning.
It just says Basel left it.
Look, case.
It's a little dusty.
Ah, ah, ah!
Achoo!
I guess we gotta kill these dust bunnies.
Let's go!
Never mind, we're fine!
Comfortable looking bed.
Small plants, they look a little sad.
Okay, well, I guess we gotta go find.
Go find Basel.
I know we killed the dust bunny,
but I'm like, ah, ah, ah!
Well...
Yes!
Stomped out of existence.
Personally, I don't like dust bunnies either.
I guess we'll find Basel.
They make me sneeze.
I don't like sneezing.
We're going this way.
Fast forest.
There's a parrot, I think.
Basel!
Basel, where are you?
I know.
I bet my pet rock will know what to do.
Heck, there'll be a good boy.
Go find Basel.
Try your best, buddy.
This is no time to fool around, Cal.
Hey, why you?
Pector was just trying to help.
I call you two.
We need to keep ourselves focused.
Squawk!
Main station.
Squawk! Squawk!
Body bridge.
Your voice is really nice to listen to.
You say that as I literally squawk.
Kill the bunny.
Oh no, it winked.
We won!
Yay, we won!
We got stuff.
There's those.
Got both of them.
Ah, give me a second.
Got bracelet.
Okay.
And now I can fight this bunny in.
Go!
Fight bunny!
Die!
No, not the bunny link.
I can do that too.
Hold on.
Pempie, are you ready?
Okay.
Got life cam.
Let's quickly grab stuff.
Let's get a bottle of juice.
Oh.
That over here, right?
Hmm. I don't know, guys.
I think Basel's in this forest.
We haven't searched the whole forest yet.
Can't stop now.
Cheer up, Aubrey.
We'll keep searching until we find them.
We don't find Basel soon.
Maybe we should meet up with Mari and the playground
and figure out what to do from there.
Bridge, right?
There it is.
Bee.
10 keys left.
Between giant pinwheels.
Hold on.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, we're here.
It's a good idea.
We'll be back.
Let's go.
We're here!
Come on.
Let's go.
I might go back because I'm just like oh
I just have Michael back because I didn't
explore that entire areola yet and I'm
kind of a type of player who wants to
complete everything
gosh
I gotta revive us again
Why is this bunny so fricking strong?!
No! Not another toast!
Okay, good, we stabbed it.
Well, that's a problem.
Whee! Whee! Whee!
I gotta run, bye.
Whoa!
No, don't touch me!
Don't, don't, don't!
Don't touch me, not yet!
What the?
Hello everyone, how's it going? Have you found Basel yet?
Hey Mari, not look so far I'm afraid.
Oh, I'm sorry guys. Sarah was the way I could help more.
We're all doing our best, maybe we should start looking outside this forest.
I know, why don't we try climbing a really long ladder?
East, one east of the stump.
Dude, that'll Mari's afraid of heights.
What if Basel somewhere up there? We gotta take her chances.
I know, but...
Oh boy, growing stronger and stronger every day.
You kind of keep climbing a ladder, can't you?
Come on little brother, face your fears.
It's natural to be nervous at first, but you should know that, we all believe in you.
Come on now Mari, just one measly little ladder.
No worries that can happen.
I'm not about this.
Are you here to be okay? Oh Mari?
No.
Okay, just take your time.
Come on now Mari, you can't just sit tight with Basel missing.
Mari, we have to do this.
I'm here to support you.
If anything happens, we'll be all here to protect you too.
Won't we all agree?
No, I guess you're right about that.
Have nothing to be afraid of as long as we're together.
Basel's probably all alone. He needs us right now.
Mari, you need to face your fears for Basel's sake.
I believe in you.
Take it slow if you like, as long as we get there eventually.
Woohoo!
Let's go, let's go to the ladder east of the stump.
I'll see you later Mari.
I know.
Stay safe.
Remember oh Mari, you're stronger than you think.
Give me a second.
Yeah, nutritious candy.
I'll probably save as well.
I yapped so much.
Hahaha.
Grumble, grumble, grumble, grumble.
Hey man, something wrong with Burley?
Seems a little upset.
Oh, about that well you see.
Let me explain.
Look at this pole.
Can't you believe it?
There's no tether ball?
What are we looking at?
Yeah, I don't see it.
Exactly!
The tether ball is missing.
And you used his arm and swung it too hard.
Now the ball has gone off somewhere.
Never to be seen again.
I thought you didn't have to use your arms man.
I'm gonna use your head.
Like this.
Sorry Burley.
Using my head.
All the time gives me a headache.
That's because you don't have a hard head like I do.
Oh, something just hit me.
I'm sure I saw the ball flying off somewhere in that direction.
Into the vast, into the vast forest?
Never find it now.
Things will be lost forever.
I don't smell it Burley.
We'll find it's ball for you.
Yeah, be sure you want to do that.
Fast forward to pretty good use place you know.
One time, game gun just super gizzy brawl with this ugly pint creature with dead empty eyes and a gaping mouth.
I outroided it.
Of course, being cool and smart and all.
There's no monster in all the universe that can't outrun me.
What?
Hey Elmore, why don't you try?
You and your friends go with Burley and keep her out of trouble.
I'll go myself, but...
Man!
Be all right, I'll be my beings again.
Oh geez, there's my cue.
I'm coming happy.
You safe out there guys.
See you when you get back.
Come on Burley.
Come on Burley, let's go find your lost ball.
You don't have anything to worry about as long as we're together.
I can't share.
Just don't get in my way when I show off my totally amazing headbutt skills.
Let's just get this over with.
Burley joined your party.
I guess I'm a little bad because where would my shop please buy something like this?
I'm gonna get some candy.
Maybe six candies.
So I can...
Heal up.
What the heck happened over here?
Rows ran over me and knocked me down, but I'm just lying here because it feels good.
Oh no, thanks.
Thanks, you're gonna be okay.
Is this anywhere in my last moment?
Is this somewhere else to be or something?
No.
Okay, I will go get your lost ball.
Oh, don't forget to use Hero's Healing Skill.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I forgot.
It's not this way, is it?
Squawk!
In the Meal Forest.
Squawk, Squawk!
Longy Bridge.
Where's this?
Okay.
I guess not.
I'll come here soon.
Oops, I ran into a bunny.
Okay.
Hi, guys.
It's a bunny.
Bye bye, bunny.
There we go.
Okay, we got it.
Where's my...
Kit?
Snacks? Tofu?
Here, I'll put Candy on.
Girl?
There you go.
All better.
What's over here?
Huh?
It's the tire swing.
Alright, we'll kill him again.
Quickly kill the sprout thing.
Huh?
Eh.
Hmm?
Some pies need another wink?
I patch on, wink.
Sorry.
Bunny, can you wait?
There we go.
I can't remember what the weaknesses were.
Like, angry over sad, okay.
Be stronger than sad.
Sad, stronger than him.
Okay.
Eh, we'll make this dish sad.
Hopefully.
Okay.
I think Omlauri has stronger...
...stronger attack.
Okay.
There we go.
We just managed to offball.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm starting to get the hang of it.
Yepa.
Oh, I'm probably gonna heal again.
I hate eggs.
I hate stepping on eggs.
I think the possibility of even stepping on eggs is disgusting.
Okay, where's that tether ball?
Yeah, Jax.
Not over here.
I say totally avoiding...
...rain station.
Hi, I'm the wise rock.
I'll give you solid advice.
It can exchange for clams.
Kind of vice.
Would you like me to give good advice?
Okay, advice.
Bad advice.
Okay.
And everyone wants...
...wants an okay...
...good advice, right?
How bad is your egg allergy?
Like, have a pen handy?
You guys wanna give a bad advice?
Okay.
Let's see.
I have...
My allergy is pretty bad.
Like, if I touch it...
...my throat constricts and stuff,
I don't need an FD pen.
I usually, if I have the first sign...
...of the allergy coming,
I will use Benadryl.
But if I eat too much...
...or ingest eggs too much,
I will need to be hospitalized.
So, yeah, that's...
I'm pretty allergic.
What is...
What is my...
If you look up a certain thing,
let me see what it's called again.
Let me see something.
What it's called again.
Yeah.
Ah, okay.
My allergy...
What happens?
Is called...
Angio...
Angioedema.
But it's...
It's worse for me,
because my throat actually swells as well.
So then I can't breathe.
So...
I have...
So I get swollen eyes.
Swollen lips.
Swollen tongue.
And my throat gets swollen as well.
So then I can't breathe.
Then I have to go to the hospital.
So...
If...
To have a visual...
Um...
Visual of what I will look like.
Just think of how...
How Pepe...
Pepe the frog looks.
I will look exactly like that.
But, um...
Sorry, I keep on falling asleep.
My motto keeps on falling asleep.
Uh, eggs are everywhere in most foods, basically.
Does this mean you have a...
A specified diet?
Uh...
I eat mostly vegan.
Mostly vegan.
Um...
Unfortunately.
It's like vegan, but not by choice.
Do you like the taste of eggs?
I've never even tasted eggs in my entire life.
Can't eat mayo either?
No, I can't have mayo.
Oh, but recently, um...
How...
How many...
How many have made a vegan mayo?
Which, apparently, according to my...
My gal pals...
It tastes...
It tastes exactly like mayo.
So I've been using that recently for my sandwiches.
Hahahaha!
I, um...
Only, I feel like, within like the past few years...
Was like when things started, uh...
People have started to accept like vegan as like...
As like a...
It started to be more of a trendy diet.
Uh...
Like, I tried...
A cake for the first time.
Like a moist cake.
For the first time in adulthood.
Hahahaha!
Now, which has got any...
Favorite kind of bread?
I don't know, I think bread is usually pretty safe.
Hahahaha!
But, uh, I tested it.
Uh, I think it's only bird eggs.
I've never tried lizard eggs.
And I'm a little too scared to try, but...
Um...
Mama!
In my youth.
I've been allergic to eggs since I was born.
So, um...
So...
Mama! Mama tried to give me a quail egg.
And that didn't go well either.
And I tried duck egg.
And I went to the hospital as well.
So, I'm pretty sure all kinds of bird eggs are bad.
And I've even tried balut.
But, uh...
I also died from that.
So, something...
Something about eggs, bad.
So, I've been to the hospital several times.
Fish eggs are fine.
I don't know why, but fish eggs are fine.
Mama tried to kill you if she tried.
Um, let's just say I...
It wasn't until a long time into my childhood
that I, um...
That the doctors have finally found out that I was allergic to eggs.
So, I was kind of like force fed.
And like eggs for a while.
A lot, um...
Oh, this is gonna sound bad.
I was...
I was punished a lot.
In my youth.
Especially by relatives.
I was punished a lot in my youth.
Because they all thought I was just a picky eater.
Then they punished you by mail.
They punished force feeding me.
It's...
It was pretty much child abuse.
And, uh...
Other methods.
But I would always say to my parents,
like, it hurts to eat.
It hurts to eat.
And they didn't get it.
They didn't get it.
They just thought I was a picky eater.
But it wasn't until, I guess,
when I was almost nearing pre-teens,
where the doctors were like,
we found out why you're hospitalized all the time.
Hahaha.
But it's fine now.
It's fine now.
Now I know what I'm allergic to and now...
and what to avoid.
So, yeah.
Hahaha.
I probably thought it was healthy back then, but no, definitely they're like, okay, no,
no, no, no, no, you're not gonna get this because I definitely, when they force fed
me to eat things, it was like hospitalized afterwards all the time.
Oops, it's fine now, don't worry.
Childhood trauma, nobody can trauma dump on me, I trauma dump on everyone else.
But yeah, my sister definitely ran away because my parents are definitely overbearing.
They are definitely overbearing, but they do love us.
They do love us, trust me, I know.
And I think they relaxed quite a bit, they relaxed quite a bit.
When I was in school though, they were very strict, they were very, very strict.
They were very strict, but then now I feel kind of weird.
I kind of feel kind of weird because now I have a lot of freedom and I don't get in trouble as much anymore.
Or even at all, I don't really get in trouble at all.
So it kind of feels weird suddenly gaining all this freedom.
I guess.
My sister ran away sort of like the moment she was able to, when she graduated high school, she was like,
okay, I'm going to study right now, bye.
Do you like it, do you miss it?
The kind of strangulating strictness, not really.
It just still feels weird, does that make sense?
It just feels strange.
Because you know, my entire life was like, I was brought up pretty strictly,
and then now it's just like, oh okay, you're an adult now, feel free to do whatever you want.
What made the change happen?
I don't know.
I guess when I, when, I guess it's at the time they were like, well, here you go.
Freedom's nice, you guys don't get that right though.
At least I don't get that right.
I guess, I guess like, they were just like, oh, you're done school now?
Do whatever you want.
But then I guess, I don't know, I guess in a way they were overbearing,
but now they're begging me not to leave.
I guess that makes sense.
Yeah.
But like I said earlier in stream, when I had an internship in Japan,
I had an internship in Japan, I moved to Japan for three months,
and I was telling Mama and Papa like, oh yeah, if I get a job there,
I might, I might, you know, I might move, I might move here.
And they said, you're moving to Japan? Okay, we're gonna come too.
They were like, they were so adamant.
And I was like, oh, I don't know, like maybe.
And they were like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, we'll get a house with you.
We'll get a house with you and we'll move in.
We'll move in together as a family.
I mean, they've already said to me like, if I ever move to Europe,
they want to come with me.
If I ever move to like Australia, they'll come with me.
If I move to the US, they'll come with me.
They'll come with me.
Man, I'm so stupid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, everyone lives in my basement.
I think, I think I might have been easy to figure it out.
Oops.
Oh, whatever.
Wow, got sad with the bag.
Anyways, yeah.
Yeah, they wanted to stick around all the times, I guess.
My bad.
So yeah, they definitely were like, oh, yeah, we want to move.
When I told them, I told my parents recently like, oh, hey, I want to move out,
but I want to move out really close so I can have my privacy.
They were like, oh, you want to move to a new house?
Sure.
Sure, everyone, right?
And I went, no, I meant alone.
Maybe alone.
No, no, you bring us with you.
Anyways, I was like, no, no, I mean, like, alone without you for my independence.
And they went, did we do something wrong?
Did we do something wrong?
Why don't you like us, like us anymore?
I was like, oh, no.
Oh, yeah, I do get it from my mom.
Is Mama Modiste also a yander?
A bit.
A bit, actually.
Actually, she went out of nowhere.
Out of nowhere, came up to me and was like, if, if, honey, honey, if you ever get a boyfriend and he hurts you, I'll kill him.
I'll fucking kill him.
She literally said, said, I'll fucking kill him.
Papa was the same thing.
It kind of does run in the family, yeah.
So, yeah, Mama, Mama was like, you know, yeah, she can be a little, she can be really scary sometimes.
Like, she, oh my gosh, sometimes I think she's psychic.
But she knows a lot, she knows a lot of things, and I'm just like.
She knows a lot of things, and it kind of scares me because sometimes she reads my mind.
Oh, yeah, she did predict my viewer career.
She, okay, do you guys, okay.
I didn't get to say this in, I didn't get to say this in debut 2.0 because I got really tired.
Because I got sick before stream and then I got really tired, so I had to only hit around like the two hour ish mark.
But, um, what was it?
Um, so Mama comes from a little bit of a family of like fortune tellers.
So in Vietnam, um, they have a fortune, uh, fortune telling, fortune telling using regular playing cards.
And so out of nowhere, she just decided to read my, read my fortune.
Mmm, no, no, no, not tarot cards, like a regular playing deck. So with like the suits and stuff.
Yeah, like kind of how you would, but it's like, uh, it's Vietnamese style.
So it's very common if you go to Vietnam, you'll see people do this type of fortune telling.
So she was like, okay, your career is something to do with the internet.
You're going to meet a woman who's going to help you achieve your goals.
Your work is going to not necessarily be normal, but if it's going to be lots of hard work,
but it's going to be lots of hard work, but it will be fruitful.
It will be fruitful and quite lucrative.
And the woman that you will meet wears primarily black or has black hair.
And that's what that's what she said. And then that was it. That was it. And this was
a month, months before I found out about violour.
Do you have fortune telling powers? I can do a bit of fortune telling.
I can do a little fortune telling, not lotto numbers, but like tarot cards.
Like tarot cards, I can do it a little bit.
But I think mama thought that teaching kids online is kind of a little bit different,
because it's not physically teaching people online and stuff.
So I guess mama thought it was something like that.
So it's not really a normal job.
So I can do it. Sometimes even my friends, they've liked my fortune
telling so much that they've actually gotten paid to do it. I'm still a beginner, Bill.
In my opinion, I'm still a beginner, but mama thinks I inherited the gift from the family.
It sounds a little weird, right? It's like, oh, you know, you're pretty good at this.
Yeah, maybe as you know, mama's side of the family has a bit of like a history to fortune
telling and stuff. I think you mentioned the fortune telling before,
or maybe Shibi said something very similar. Probably. It was probably, maybe Shibi mentioned it.
We talked about like tarot cards and stuff, because they're kind of into like that as well.
I do a lot of good luck stuff, because I don't know, it just makes me feel safer.
It's just for fun, though. It's just for fun. Fortune telling and stuff is just for fun.
So don't take it seriously, guys. Don't take it seriously, Senpai.
But yeah, mama, mama, mama definitely pulled me out of nowhere and did that. And you know what?
Because she's my mama. I'm generally like, okay, I'm listening. I don't know why she does it,
how she does it, but like, you know, every time she says something bad will happen today, don't go
out. And then like, you know, I go out and then something terrible happens. And I'm like, oh,
I saw, I listen, I listen to her a lot.
I listen to her a lot, because I'm just like, she knows something that I don't.
She knows something that I don't, I don't.
You know, it's just one of those things where I'm like,
okay, I don't know a whole lot about this, but I'm just going to listen to my mama.
That advice time.
Understood. Here is your advice. Don't be ugly.
You hear that, senpai? I hope this helps.
Sounds like a good advice to me. Solid advice.
Not gonna lie, my entire PC, Wi-Fi and power shut down, right? This is about how we talked about
tarot cards. Oh, shit. Yeah, I don't know, mama, it's probably a coincidence, but like, mama,
mama truly believes in that type of stuff. So I, I tend to listen to her because I feel like,
I don't know, you ever have the sage mother and father advice. And then you're just like,
yeah, they know something more than I do. So I'm just going to listen. I don't care if it sounds
kind of weird. I don't care if it sounds kind of weird or if it sounds like, you know, like
weird, bad, just, uh.
So I just listen, listen to mama.
But yeah, mama is trying to teach me to do Vietnamese fortune telling,
but it's so complex and I don't know certain words and I'm just like, I don't get it.
I don't get it.
I don't get it. This is hard. I just stuck with tarot cards instead because I was like, okay,
this I can understand.
Maybe a stream to practice? I don't know.
I would not allow mama, mama, modest to come teach on stream. I would not allow them. Listen,
if they asked me, honey, Netflix stopped working. Can you call them and tell them to make it work
again? You think I'm going to let them on stream?
Immediately, immediately, I would get Doc's hardcore. Are these your students, sweetie?
Hi from address, address, address, address, address, address.
How do you know my
Like I would be instantly Doc's. I could make an entire, listen, listen, listen.
Listen, it took me years and I have still not have succeeded in teaching Papa how to use a cell
phone, a flip phone. I, when I, I was like, here to pick up, you just open the phone and you know
what, what Papa did?
He said, okay, I got it. He opens the flip phone and closes it again and puts it against his
ear and goes, hello, it's not working.
Oh my gosh. And I, I didn't even know.
Do you know how hard it was to teach them how to use Netflix?
It was pretty hard and I taught them and I was only able to teach them because the, the little, uh,
the, the remote that come, I don't know, I think it was like a Blu-ray player
comes with the remote that says, that has a button that says Netflix.
And I just like, click this button, tap this button and it will take you to Netflix.
And then if you want to watch, watch anything, press these button and hit okay.
Okay. It took me a long time.
It took me a long time, but I managed to teach them how to use Netflix.
It's, it was tough. It was tough. So there is no way. I'm sorry. I'm sorry,
but you will not be able to meet my, my parents on stream.
I've tried multiple times to tell them what my job is and they said, oh, you teach. Oh, okay.
So you, you teach kids online how to speak English, right?
And at this point, I say, yeah, sure.
I just say, do they call you every time Netflix logs out the account? Yes. Yes, they do.
They do. If they go on the wrong profile, they start crying and telling me,
why isn't there old, their show that they were currently watching on this profile?
No.
But how will we ask them for your hand in marriage or lie? Well,
I already have a plan set up. So don't step out of it. Okay. Senpai.
So I was like, it's okay though. They think that every anime I watch is either Inuyash or
Sailor Moon cause I was obsessed with them as a kid. So please trust me. This is a,
this is a long process, but I promise Senpai, we'll have our happily ever after together.
Just trust, trust the process. Trust the process.
Don't worry, they'll meet you.
For now, though, they believe that you're my little student.
That's what they believe. You're my, you're my, you're my Senpai, but they believe that you're my
students. I think that's really funny though. I think it's really funny.
So remember, let's have a little secret together.
I still have to get used to my new, new routine.
I'm also sad. Wow.
I'll just, I'll just beat these guys first and then run to like a save point and then we'll do a
little chat and then I'll um, and then I'll, I'll head on.
So
that's the wrong way. I do have to go this way.
Through it, we're running.
Bye.
They know you're trying to leave.
They know they're, that I'm trying to leave and that they want me to stay just like my Senpai.
Right?
Okay. Yeah, let's save here.
Ooh.
Oh wait, everybody saved.
I forgot how to get to the menu again.
All right.
And close your eyes, Senpai. Flashbang.
Back to color.
Um, um, um.
Sorry I cough so, so much Senpai and like player might throw it a lot. I've been a bit sick.
Actually ever since before, the day before debut. I think I got a bit sick from basically stress.
Stress, nerves, all of the emotions rolled up into one.
So I've been, I've been coughing a little bit
and clearing my throat a little bit more. I do get a little bit flummy. So yeah.
Feeling better now? I think I'm getting to the tail end of it, but I still have like the cough and stuff.
I feel bad that I'm not always in my like tip top shape when uh, screaming.
Yeah. Yeah, debut was so stressful for me. When I first did debut, I was, I was, I wanted to make
such a good impression because I was worried that a lot of people would scrutinize the allure
more than usual. So I really tried my best. I tried my best to make a good first impression.
So yeah, and I was worried that, that you know, after debut, um, you know, people would be like,
would be, would scrutinize, scrutinize a little more as well.
So I was like, oh no, I have to impress my senpais. After all, I'm their kohai
and, and they'll need to love me and I'll be really sad if they don't like me.
So I'm really happy that I made, uh, at least a decent impression on my senpais.
Well, as long as, uh, everything's all good.
Okay, I leaned my arm onto this table so much, made an event.
So yeah, let's see if I have any, any news or something coming up. Let me take a look.
See, I know it's pretty light right now. Sorry for yapping so much about my family.
Here, let's see my schedule. Well, all my, I've, I've posted up all my schedule already.
I'm pretty, pretty cool with that.
Uh, okay, we have merch from Uwu Market. That's already done. Tomorrow is my
first ever ASMR stream.
It's my first ever ASMR stream, so I hope, uh, senpais will tune into that.
Am I a little nervous? Yeah, I'm a little nervous about it. Um, I had some things planned,
but because of, um, YouTube kind of cracking down on certain things, I'm going to have to just
readjust some things. Um, it's going to be safe for work. So have no worries about that. I'm not
going to go, you know, but I'm going to, uh,
I mean, is I'm here?
Oh, hi! I'm from Umapluses here. Wow. Umapluses is, uh, is another,
is, uh, is another, uh, V2 company that everyone should check out. Really cute girls.
Um, so, um, let's see, my, my ASMR stream is going to be, uh, a lot of pampering. I went out already.
I went out and got everyone, um, the kind of, the, the, the ice globe, the ice globe rollers,
and I've got, uh, a gel mask, uh, that I think makes a nice sound, I think. Um,
um, so I'm going to try to pamper, pamper my senpais.
Do you do heartbeat? Um, I'm not sure I'll do heartbeat.
Um, I think you'll have to go tomorrow to see what I'm planning. I'm not sure if it's going to be,
um, typical because I, I, to be honest, I'm just jumping and blinded.
Uh, to be honest, I'm jumping and blind, so I've, I've never really watched, um, other ASMR videos.
Yeah, it's going to be whispers. I promise you it'll be relaxing. It'll be relaxing whispers.
So, I, I haven't studied visually or auditorially because I don't know, I just,
I'm very sensitive to sound, so I, I have trouble studying, um, other people's videos, so I've been
kind of doing it in a way where I've been just reading about it.
So, I'm definitely going to pamper, pamper my, my senpais.
I'm going to pamper my senpais, but uh, don't worry though. I've been studying sometimes,
a lot of times. Strawny send me things if she's like, you need improvement in this area. Here,
here's an example. I do take the time to watch those videos that she sends me.
So, hopefully, uh, it works out. I'm going to see if it works. Let me know. Senpais, I hope you let me
know if something's, uh, too strong or too sensitive, so I'm not really sure, um, about how ASMR is,
but I did, I did some reading, I did some reading about it, so hopefully I'll do it in my own little way.
If it's Strawny, those are probably some interesting training videos.
Am I allowed to say this?
Sometimes Strawny's like, nope, that wasn't good enough. Here, go practice.
And then I would have to re-record and stuff.
Strawny, Strawny, um, definitely is, is, uh, guiding me, guiding me a lot.
So, um, if something, there's, there's one I know, I'm not very proud of my very first,
one of my very first audios for Patreon. I'm not very proud of, so what if you, if you hear it?
I think I did an okay job on it, but I feel like I
would, I would improve, I should improve more. I'm learning from my mistakes,
so I feel like it's not, it's not the best quality, it's because I am a beginner.
Enjoy learning? Of course, I enjoy learning. It's, it's a part of my likes, my hobbies.
I love research, I love learning. I very much have kind of like a research-esque mind.
So yeah, uh, please understand if, if there's any harsh comments, uh, this, uh, when I first recorded
all of those, uh, all of those, uh, recordings were definitely, uh, a month plus in advance.
So, the following month should be better, but I think it might be, I think I'm still,
still learning, so I'll try to improve over time.
The first audio was good, good. I think that one was, I think I found a little more confident in
that one. In, in, in that one, uh, so Strani's definitely helping me. The other girls, girls,
uh, are definitely helping me as well. So yeah, uh, I think a lot of us are, are definitely noobs,
but I think, uh, they've, they've dabbled, they've dabbled in, in ASMR a little bit more than me.
Me, I, I'm completely new, I'm completely new, so I'm just like, oh okay, Strani's, Strani's has taught
me in her own way. Um, yeah. Azura said she's new too. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think Azura is not
ignorant. When I came in, I was like, I don't even know what a trigger is.
I was like, trigger? Like, oh my devil trigger.
Oh, like a gun trigger. Is that a popular race?
Is there a way would you like feedback structured or would you let, let you go on your own pace?
Um, I think Strani and I know where my weaknesses are, but I don't mind a little bit of constructive
criticism, but not mean criticism. I will cry. And if I go, if I cry, uh, someone's gonna pay for it.
I hope that makes sense.
Uh, you can give my feedback through my moral. It's fine. I do read through my morals. I'm sorry
I haven't really replied to a lot of them. I, I have been reading all of them though, but a lot
of questions that have been coming in have been things I've already addressed. So I was like,
I don't know if I should answer this or I'm, or I'm shy about answering because some of them are very,
if you are very personal and I'm just like, uh, I'm very thankful and they're, they're mine.
They're mine and only mine. No, I'm not even Senpai gets to see my reaction.
What limits do you have on questions mask? No, you mean, what do you mean?
Like, what questions do I not like?
Um, I guess questions that blushing mercy. Yeah. If I read some of them, I'm like,
what do you want us to not ask about? Well, if things have are, are kind of easily findable.
So like, if you're like, oh, do you play hentai games or arrow gay?
Well, I address that in my debut. Um, if I, if, oh, do you like this anime and it's in my debut,
I'm going to be really, I get a little, I get a little miffed, you know?
I get a little miffed if someone asks me, how do I, uh, if they ask me a question about how
the internal system works? I don't know. That's a question for strongy.
So risk a questions are fine for you. Yes. Uh, although I may not answer it because, um, it's a journey.
It's a journey. It's a journey for me.
So, uh, yeah, kayfabe questions are okay. I feel a little bad because I dropped kayfabe a lot.
Um,
yeah, I feel like most questions are free and on the table if, oh, I know some questions that I don't
like. I've been recently getting questions that I don't like, that I know that I don't like. I feel
like they're baiting for me to answer in order to, to induce some rage. And I don't like that.
I don't like that. And I think those are not my senpais. I think those are trolls.
I think those are trolls. So I don't like that. I don't like questions about, um,
like pineapple and pizza kind of question. No, no, no, like, uh,
more offensive questions, you know?
So, like pineapple and pizza, by the way, is good. My favorite pizza is pineapple in
my room. So anyone else can fight me. You can try.
But like questions that are definitely, um,
definitely questions that are definitely trying to get a riot out of me or someone else. Does that
make sense? So I don't like political questions. I don't like, um, questions about,
like, personal things about me. So, um, no, let's just, I, I've, instead, I haven't seen
any of my morals yet, but I've had people ask me questions in the past where it's like,
where do you live? Tell me where you live. What's your phone number? I want to give you a call,
personal call. That type of thing. I don't like things by invading my privacy. So those are
kind of like, I feel like it's kind of common. These are common questions.
But I definitely don't like questions that are like, you know, trolls and stuff. So,
yeah, so it's, it's kind of like the basic etiquettes. Just remember basic etiquettes and
most likely I will, I will answer it or I will keep that question in my mind to answer in the
future because maybe I don't know. I don't know. And I'm, I'm still discovering pieces of myself as
well. So for example, I don't know how to, like, if someone says, what are you into? I feel like
the, that question's a little hard for me because I don't really know what I'm into.
And I'm also slowly discovering what I'm into and what I'm not into, I guess.
Like, yeah.
Those questions are fine. I just feel like I don't have the ability to answer them now.
I don't have the knowledge of myself to answer them now.
Things like that.
So, we're all, we're all learning together. And then once I find out if I don't like something,
I'll let you know.
It's like trying food, you know, I'm still trying a lot of food. So I don't really know, like, oh,
I do like this, but, oh, do you, I've never tried this before. So I don't know if I like it or not.
That makes us your students. Your mom was 100% on our prediction. I think it's more like
senpais are teaching me, I think. I think my senpais are more like mentoring me.
I know my mods are supposed to be silent, but I thank you for my mods as well. I see a lot of
senpais also show appreciation for them. So thank you. Thank you mods. Shut up, but also thank you.
I truly, I truly do appreciate the hard work.
So I really appreciate them. Shout outs, shout outs to mods.
Especially when I say things like cut off his testicles.
My lesson to me. I'm so appreciative of that.
No, they're doing really good.
Good. But yeah, I appreciate it. This is actually my first time talking to so many people as well.
So I appreciate having all the help that I can get, especially the, my gen mates help me a lot,
and scrawny helps me a lot, and manager helps me a lot.
Mods destroy them. Next time I'll be like, oh, look, I pulled out my mods card.
Maw moderators obliterate.
Put mods in attack mode.
And I put one of my mods face down.
Wait, do you actually know Yu-Gi-Oh? I've only watched the anime. I've never really played it.
I don't know how to play like Yu-Gi-Oh Yu-Gi-Oh, but I've only watched the anime. I think the first season.
So I only know a few cards as well, mostly Exodia. In fact, I have like, do you guys know that collab
with Hello Kitty? The McDonald's collab? Hello Kitty? And it's like the Yu-Gi-Oh Hello Kitty
collab? I have like, on one of my, one of my lights here. I forgot to turn off my lights,
turned on my lights today, but one of my lights here is a pom-pom pudding Exodia.
Yeah, that's Hello Kitty with Yu-Gi-Oh's hair. It's hilarious, right? So I have, I have that one.
I have, that's the one I wanted. That's the one I wanted. I also have,
wow, this one I'm going to give to a friend of mine. I have Pochakko as the time wizard.
And I have my melody as a dark magician girl. And I also have
um, uh, the cinnamon roll blue eyes my dragon. What's your favorite Hello Kitty character,
Kohai? Um, pom-pom pudding. I love, I love pom-pom pudding's butthole. I think it's a charm point.
I think it's cute. What? What do you mean? No one knows about the butthole? Everyone,
look at pom-pom pudding's butthole. I think it's cute. If a product does not have the butthole,
I do not buy it. I do not buy it. Um, my second favorites are probably Little Twin Stars. I think
they're cute. Is my end area Hello Kitty girl? Um, I don't own a lot of Hello Kitty stuff. I do
like Hello Kitty, but I don't own a lot of Hello Kitty stuff. So if, for example, uh, I don't just
buy things because it's Hello Kitty or anything. To be honest, I'm kind of like trying to not really
want a lot of things. So the things on my wish list are kind of like things that I've been like
thinking about a lot or just a tiny treat. Uh, mostly from, I think a lot of them are just things
that I, I think will improve my stream. So things that will help improve my stream. So, uh, right
now, uh, the Senpai, thank you Senpais for gifting me things, uh, so far. Um, I'm still reading through
it. I, I'm actually, I recently received a, uh, the, the nausea, uh, bracelet thing. So hopefully
it works out for some streams so that I can, I can use that. I'll test that out for streams, uh,
for first person stuff. Uh, the blanket is already behind me. It's kind of airing out right now,
because it's, it's kind of, it arrived kind of like with the factory sense. So I'm, I'm airing it
out a little bit. Um, it's working great right now. If it's working great, if you can hear my audio,
um, I'm kind of, I'm kind of happy with my audio. I'm happy with my audio,
with my audio setup right now. I think it's pretty good. I think it's pretty good. Uh,
I've covered some areas where I think, uh, has a little bit of a reverberation. I've,
I've covered those areas. So I think, I think it's pretty good now. I think, uh, mind you,
the space I'm in right now that I can only fit myself in is like kind of, is the open area in
the basement is the open area in the basement. So there's like stairs here and like lots of
crevices and stuff. So I'm trying my best. I'm trying my best. I tried my best to sound, uh,
as, as good as possible for my supplies. Um, yeah, I'm raining through some of the manuals for some
stuff. Uh, everything arrived. Everything, everything's arrived. So yeah.
Thought the Ku 100 mic, isn't that like $8,000? Now it's way more than that.
Uh, I put an LOL on that. It was kind of a joke. It was kind of a joke.
It's a, it's more of a joke. I put it there for like, ha ha, look at me. I'm so passionate about ASMR.
There's a reason why in there it says, uh, it says LOL.
You say that until it's bought. I don't think anyone's going to buy that, to be honest.
Do you guys think, uh, I should take it off then?
You should take it off the list then? I put it there as like kind of like a,
uh, I'm, I'm, uh, I'm, I'm experimenting and I hear it's pretty good, but it's, it's quite a big upgrade.
I think, uh, if I had to choose one thing that I would really, really, really want,
would be the U87. I think I would really love the U87 more than the Ku 100.
Keep it on, keep it on, keep it, take it off. Maybe, maybe I should take it off.
I don't know. I feel a little guilty for putting it on because I, uh, maybe that,
I put the precedence on, um, someone, someone to, to try to get it.
Yeah, I'll probably remove it. Heck, I'll remove it right now.
Whoa, I can remove it right now. Don't worry, Sunpie.
There you go. It's gone into the ether.
It's gone now. Excuse me. Wow.
But yeah, um, my wishlist stuff, yeah.
Haha.
Vanished.
Are you okay? Hi, yeah, yeah, yeah, sorry. I just feel I'm still a little bit of sick,
so I will get like, plummy and coffee all the time, all the, every once in a while.
It's also pretty cold in the basement, so I get pretty sick easily in the basement.
I'm streaming like right beside all my supplies
Yeah, I sent it to the shadow realm
That's a tea by the way
Good, but it's so cold down here. Like usually these mugs can hold
Can hold like
Heat for a while, but because it's so cold down here. It can get
Really fast and go get cold really fast
Yeah, we know it's cold. I provided lots of blankets
Yeah, you're about to hit the five hour mark. Oh shit. I'm such a yapper. I'm sorry
Can we try using a thermos for your tea I
I didn't think about that
I was like I do have a thermos as far soup though
But I'm also like I kind of wanted to cool it down a little bit. I may be at thermos might be too hot
I
Don't worry. I already have one. I already have a thermos. I bought it for soups. I actually bought it for school
Uh, I ended up not using it for school
So I guess I was saving it for camping or something
I'm camping with senpai. Let me know the forest. Don't worry about the barrel and the bone saw and
you know the copulous amount of
Acid
That I'm bringing along. I don't look good. I don't like that. Do you like camping? I do like the outdoors. I
Like the outdoors. It's calming
Someone said they found a bone while we were cleaning our ping-pong mess earlier. Oh, don't worry about it
This isn't in the beach this is an acid bag
I
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. But yeah, yeah, I'll take I'll take it off most things. I just kind of want or
Or I
It's things to improve the screen except for the size of fumo
That's kind of like a want because I don't know. I don't have a lot of saw. I'm a really big fan of siren outa
A new plan on keeping us from running off in the forest
Ah
Sometimes, you know, maybe a little broken ankle might might hurt hurt your chances a little bit
I
Give you a head start not without a handicap, of course
Don't want to run. Yeah
Well, if you don't want to run then we'll have a good time because then I'll be like camping and then we'll have s'mores and like
We'll roast
Roast things over a fire and tell camp stories and stuff. But if you want to run
I'll give you a head start
But you know
Maybe the animals will find you first
Whatever happened in the og senpai check out the lore video
I
Think like if we roast like, you know things over like I would love I would love to have like sweet potatoes
Over an open fire. I'll be really nice
So I think that'll be really nice to to have and like maybe have like our own little like
Fire pit barbecue wouldn't that be nice?
Is this a plan for a date of course
And then we can look at the stars together wouldn't that be nice
Like real sweet potatoes are really nice. I love it. I love it a lot
So
But if you if if senpai's decided to start running
Wow, I did bring some stuff to to help
Oh, there'll be beer. I don't really like beer actually. I don't really like drinking or
Any any vices really
It makes my senses go dull and I don't like that. I like to be alert at all times
I like root beer though. Yeah, root beer is okay
I think I got a really bad memory. Um when I was in college
Um, I went to the local like the student the student
our pub, I don't know. I don't know the difference to be honest
um
and I yeah, I was with a a group of uh
group of classmates and
Ended up leaving because I hate I hated it. I hated it. So the beer came
Uh
beer came and
Okay, uh
It was poured out into the drinks and it'll be my first time trying beer. It's like, oh, I've never tried beer before
I swear it smelled like piss it was warm
It was warm
It smelled really bad and when I tasted it it tasted like, you know
P and I was like the fucking person who served this to us like just pissing a jug
Look
Great, have you tried tried pee it tasted like what pee smells like
So it was like warm and it felt it looked like
P and I was like
Ah
It's just smells bad and it was warm and then I I was like
I asked I asked I asked the the staff I was like this is this normally served warm and they're like
Yeah, beers normally served warm like it's best. Uh, it's best uh
beer tastes best at like when it's like
You know warm and I was like
I'm gonna pay for my part and I'm gonna leave
I
I uh I left I left I I literally almost threw up in that cup. I like spat it out
Uh, I spat it out so I
I
I I I uh that was my first interaction with beer and I've never liked beer ever since
I've never liked beer ever since so if anyone just offers me beer
I just think of that moment even if it's cold. I still taste like I drink it. I'm like
You just like alcohols, um
I don't dislike it, but I tend to avoid alcohol
It it uh dulls the senses and if it dulls the senses, I can't I can't
Be at my peak around my senpai's
Like um if I'm around my gal pals my my friends, uh, we'll probably drink a little bit of like
I don't know like a long island iced tea something sweet, you know or like those
Baileys or something, but I uh last time I went drinking with workers. I uh got shit-based and uh
I'm not a good drunk. Let's just say I'm not a good drunk
Um, yeah, I'm not a good drunk. I think I told them I hated them or something
I hated them and then I hated my work and everything in front of the my boss. So let's let's not just oh, yeah, it's not
It's not good
so, uh
Did you hate them um sometimes I did
Sometimes I did so
I guess those feelings, you know one of frustrations when I was frustrated with my co-workers
um
Yeah, I'm gonna so if anyone asked for a drinking stream that's not happening
Well, will you tell us if you were drunk with us? I probably just bitch about how you keep on trying to run away from me
I was the next day at work that was my last day at work
We were doing a drinking celebration for my last day of work
I just went
Uh, so I uh, I don't drink
I don't drink and the last time and the time before that when I drunk I
uh sober I was sober in front of
The in front of the toilet uh with my barfinette. So I was like, uh, you know what?
Screw drinking
Screw screw drinking
So I don't like drinking
I
Yeah, so I I I prefer to keep my health up, especially since my health isn't the greatest
I guess my biggest vice would be like the occasional drunk food
Like um
I know like mama mama and papa's favorite celebration food is it's fried chicken and I do like fried chicken too
So yeah, I I was like I don't like, uh, I don't like drinking
So
Yeah, uh like, uh, we're basically like birthdays and stuff are celebrated with fried chicken
So I don't really I don't drink I do keep some
I've already reached five hours. Congratulations to me. Not not my record, but
Um
I do keep some drinks around with me or like, uh, if my gal pals if we're having like a a girly sleepover
We're having a girly sleepover. They want they want a little drink. Uh, I I I I I keep some just in case
Seven hours to beat strannies strannies records strannies record is 12 hours. What are you talking about?
I I do have a lot of endurance yesterday though, I definitely
Didn't have a lot of endurance probably because before I was doing the the 2.0 and I was really stressed
Oh seven hours to go five plus seven. Wow. I'm so stupid. See this is why I hate numbers. I can't do math
But yeah, if senpais like, uh, beer and stuff I will provide beer
Or like a drink for my senpais, but I won't participate myself
Are you still feeling tired? I'm still feeling tired, but I'm a yapper. It's like
You ever keep talking while you're you're like in bed
with your friends
I don't I don't know if this is a universal thing, but you're like still chatting with your friends on discord or something
And you still have the energy, but you're like, I'm so freaking tired
So, yeah, um
I know I know people find it like weird, but like
Uh, I like sleepovers with my my my my gal pals
so uh
Some uh, we'll lay like a little futon for the floor for some girls
Girls to sleep down on the floor or and then there's a bed that everyone can share as well
So, yeah
I don't know. I don't know if most people do that
But like that's like a thing that my friends do and then we we stay up and then we talk about our lives and we talk
About anything maybe theory
Maybe we watch, uh cartoons
Uh, like we marathon cartoons and stuff
So
What do you guys talk about these secret gal pals sleepovers? Oh, yeah, we like summon demons and sacrifice
Sacrifice are uh a galt just kidding
It's terrifying right now. Stop. I do hope be allure has have an off collab sleepover
I really do hope like that. I I really want to like hang out with the girls. Maybe we can do our nails and stuff
It might take a while though since we're we've got to
Congregate at one at one place and I'm gonna guess
We congregate at one place was probably gonna be at scrawny's place. So it might take a little bit of a while
So I think uh
No, I think I think we're most likely to likely to go to scrawny's
uh
Maybe um
I'd probably have to rent out if they come to me I'd have to rent out a b&b
Uh air b&b or or book a hotel room or something
but
uh
But if we go to anywhere anywhere else we'll probably have to do something similar like that
I mean if off of you allure girls it might be a far travel for some of them as well
I'm sure it'll be fine
um
Just tell your parents very fellow teachers. I think they'll be most likely
Okay with it if I'm if I'm making a bit of money and then I'm like, okay, I'm going on a little business trip
They'll be like, yeah, okay, whatever. Bye
Something like that, I think it'll be really fun and then we can like go out and have girly
Uh girly like cafe hopping or something. I think that'll be great
I
Think it'll be great. I I would love I would love that. I would love to to meet them
Um, they're also very sweet and I love them very much and I I'm very protective of them like
I'm very protective of them
I'm very protective of the girls. So like I feel like you know, if someone
Hurts their feelings. I'm like that person. They're dead to me
Oh
Like oh
Yeah, and we've all we've all been in calls and stuff and hung out and you know
It's really nice. It's really nice. I love them. I love them very much
Uh
I'm I'm lucky to have my gen maze as my friends as my friends and my gen maze
I'm really happy because uh, sometimes we talk about things like oh like what do I do like
You know
personal things
We talk about like personal things together and goals and you know
Um, when we first came in I think
I think all of us kind of like started to just talk about and kind of gushed scrawny
About how thankful we were to be here
Ha ha ha
Like honestly we were like I'm so happy to be here. I'm so glad that you gave us a chance
Sometimes we we talk about uh
What do we talk about we just talk about anything to be honest like oh cool
Look at this cute lip lip gloss. Wow and everyone's like oh that lip gloss is so cute
That's kind of that kind of thing, you know, it's fairly normal stuff that we talk about
Yeah, like something demons
Sometimes we give each other advice about things like oh, you know, uh, it's my first time doing
This type of stream. How do I fix it or like oh my audio is being kind of funky? Uh, let's let's troubleshoot it together
Kind of things like that
Or if we're like sad about something and you know, we talk about it, you know
Oh, and of course the girls share their pet their pet uh faultles
and videos of their pets as well
It's fairly fairly. Uh, what's the word am I looking for inoculus?
This is inoculus
Yeah, it's pretty
Do I have pets? No
I don't have pets. Uh mama and papa don't like animals. So I don't have a pet
How cute are emmy's rats pretty cute
I love seeing like their pets and sometimes when we're in calls
Would you get a pet? Maybe
Um
Maybe I'm I'm not very familiar with pets since I've never really grown up with any so uh, so that's a maybe
um
Depending on financial situation. I might get a pet if I can provide with them the best that I can then I would get a pet
What pet would you get maybe a cat um or a dog?
Probably something basic
Maybe a dog. I'm I'm a little bit of allergic. I'm a little bit allergic to cats
I'm a little bit allergic to the I think long-haired cats. I sneeze a lot at my eyes, kid. Don't teary
We're not your pets. Of course you're my pets
But like if you wanted like a little fluffy fluffy little friend, you know
What happened to the dog that uses cage before us I bought it new
All right, I got it off of uh, Facebook marketplace
It depends how much cage it is
They're they're not cheap
I
Clean it first, of course I cleaned it
Yeah, I'm so thoughtful
Brand new cage never used before Facebook
Only the best for senpai
I should probably head to bed now though senpai
Uh the teabag slapped me. That's what I get for joshing around
So yeah, um, what was I gonna say? Uh, yeah tomorrow is my first time as a mar followed by that. Um
Uh, I'm gonna sound like a broken record, but some people are new here and I just want to remind everyone
But after that, it will be a difficult game about climbing. That is going to be a very loud game
So if you're expecting my soothing voice, you're gonna get a lot more screams instead
Uh designing jimmies outfits, uh, they're gonna be your kind of rough sketches. So my idea is like, you know, lovely date outfits
Lovely date outfits
And uh
After that is harvester and then deathmark and then the following
Week after will be a bit of a slowdown slowdown. So I will
Probably slow down to around three streams
and then slowly
slowly build up to five five, uh
five streams a week, uh, we're uh
This uh week is full because um
Because I
Want to definitely I want to show off off fastest fastest of me to senpai
And it's debut week. So I want to show off
fastest, uh, and I don't have anything else to do
That sounds bad, but I I just I just really want to spend time with everyone
I I don't have any prior engagements this week as well
I don't have any prior engagements. Uh next week though, I'll probably on my day off uh days off
I'll probably catch one chore that I was supposed to do
I'll probably uh, and then I'll probably uh
Uh
Yeah, I'll I'll do chores and do some work on my day on my days off
It sounds bad doing work on your days off, but it's like, you know things that I'll only take, uh,
maybe two hours or so
Like uh to prepare uh things for streams and uh
Hrion and stuff
Tell senpai to do his chores
Do your chores
If the cage is clean
Uh, uh keep the cages clean. Um
I think the biggest chore that I want for all my senpais is to take care of yourself
Be at your best. Go out meet your friends
Uh try a new hobby. That's my
That's my homework for my senpais
Oh, and yeah, watch all of cardcaptor sakura
You're welcome
Cardcaptor sakura as they do in two weeks
So yeah
Hmm
So you so yeah, that's your homework take care of yourself everyone. Uh, let's see
Okay, if it's if 70 episodes and two movies are too much I'm only asking you for for the
First and second season and the two movies from the original one not clear card
Um, so everyone I hope you guys, uh
Take care. I'll see you guys again tomorrow with a a smart stream. Hey, hey senpai
Get some pie come closer. I'm closer to the screen. Okay. Come close to the screen. Okay. Are you coming close?
And I'm talking you in good night
Okay, scream for mercy. Bye. Bye